Um, okay. Somebody's asking if they can talk to you. His name's
a Cheeto. Do you want to? >> Yeah. I don't I don't mind.
>> Okay. A Cheeto. >> Uh-huh. So, spoiler alert.
This is not a >> How are you? I'm under the water. Please
help me. You're too much breathing. >> How are you? I'm
under the water.
>> Never mind.
>> Okay. Well done. >> All right. Okay. >> Okay.
All right. >> All right. Uh, >> we stand with Destiny
against Ethan Klein. Okay. sacrificed a thousand
barely legal or barely illegal young women
to one gay stuff. Uh-huh.
>> Wait, hold on. Let me see this. Let me see this. Let
me see this. No, no, no. I'm way more interested in this >> Sure.
They had access to all of the DMs and we're not sure if uh uh
like the uh
>> Well, no. part of the the that they had to surrender
to evidence when when they initially requested evidence. Um,
and it came to like the point where they were uh past I forget
the name of it, but there's like a period where like you argue
about things before you get the evidence and then you guys have
to give the evidence and that was part of what he had to give
was all of his DMs with Rose. If that was the case, then why
wouldn't Destiny have told Willie that I have to hold on to this
because I surrendered it to the court and did my lawyers told
me to hold on to it?
>> He said, "I literally have a court order telling me
that I have to that I can't delete all of these things because
they're part of evidence." He did say >> willing. He He
didn't say he had a court order. He said he was told or he's
cannot delete it because uh he has an active lawsuit. not necessarily
that he's is uh he has a court order and
he also said that he doesn't know if he could delete it. He gave
two contradictory statements.
>> Yeah. So so it's there's a couple of like things there.
So one, I do know that there's a court order saying that he's
not supposed to delete these things. Two, I know that as your
point >> to be clear, we know he has >> to the point
that you're >> we know he has a court >> why is there
a court order saying that his lawyers can't hold on to this information
for him or an authority can't hold on to this information for
him or >> Yeah. Sure. But it that's not deleting a DM.
That's deleting a video that you got from a DM. That's a separate
thing. Oh, >> sure. So So I I'm going to I'm going to address
it just one, we know that he has court orders to not delete any
evidence. Um, two, the we know that the Rose uh DMs are part
of the evidence that they're looking into. And then three, we
know that at another point he went and deleted all of his DMs
with everybody on Discord. And immediately there was a court
order that came through or a motion saying that he was uh uh
engaging in spoliage, which is just deleting evidence from this.
and they had to go through a whole process of
uh figuring out whether or not he did engage in spoliage and
he showed that he has all of his backed up on hard driv Did you
cut out or did you stop talking?
>> No. Can you still Can you hear me? >> To be honest,
I'm like 2 seconds away from switching to Tom's stream cuz I
know Tom's going to have audio and Rey's going to have the worst
audio. >> Are you done with that? I didn't stop >> Oh,
my bad. >> No, I I was still talking. I I don't know why
I cut out, but yeah, they were talking about whether or not he
engaged in spoliation.
But yeah, this just immediately effed for me. >> And then
he had to prove that he had all of this backed up on like hard
drives, USBs, like all this. So he had that was like part of
the case early on.
>> Okay. But what I'm saying is that number one, he gave
two contradictory uh statements to Willie Mack. Do first of all,
do we agree on that? Uh what were the contradictory statements?
>> So he told Willie Mack he doesn't think he's allowed
to delete it. >> And then in another statement he said
what you what you did say
which is um I have to hold on to it for like legal
>> Which one is it? He either knows that he has to hold
on to it or he doesn't think that he's allowed to delete it.
So, I think I I don't Yeah, I would say that the the fact that
he says I don't think is what's like giving that a lot of room
there that makes it unsure. Um, he
I don't know. I think the the argument that I've been saying
is that it's obvious that he knows he is allowed to have it because
he has court orders saying that he's not allowed to delete it,
but that doesn't mean that like he specifically has to have a
USB that is his lawyers can have it, but he likely has he has
access to all of the information that his lawyers have. So, it's
going to be that he has access to it one way or the other. And
so, yeah, I think that's >> I I'm not sure that's I'm I'm
not sure that's how that works. I'm like I'd be willing to bet
I mean again I'm not a lawyer I'm speculating here. If you have
cam that's pertinent to a case I don't think you can just surrender
to your lawyers and your lawyers are just going to be like here
you can just watch these videos whenever you want. I'm pretty
sure you're going to have to surrender them to the authorities
and there's losing this. >> Well that's why I said that
I think lawyers to tell the judge to so that they can actually
go through the process of of possibly getting rid of all this.
>> yeah. But wouldn't this happen literally at like the
beginning of the court case >> like during like discovery
and stuff like that? >> If he just now found out that she's
under 18 then no. It would happen right >> So, so well
it's it's not that they found out that like for sure because
I'm not even sure how the courts would handle whether or not
the the level of evidence that like has been presented or the
speculation or whatever that's been pres presented. I'm not sure
how they would handle that. But what my statement is is that
um
we don't know whether or not he surrendered these over to the
court prior. We don't know. You could say that he surrendered
the messages over. Do you know if he surrendered all of the messages
in totality? If they were unedited, unaltered in totality cuz
I don't think we know that. >> So hold on. as well. As
well, I would just like to say that I'm asking I I messaged Really
just dude, can you confirm that Tom knows that Destiny was told
by Solo, who he claims is the producer of these videos, right,
that she was a minor in November of 2024? >> I'm dating
all the way back to the beginning. I I don't think we know for
a fact that all of the messages, unedited and unaltered, are
in the possession of the court. >> I'm almost positive
they are. Like, I'm almost positive that they he uh cuz I remember
him saying that he had to like actually request uh data from
Discord. Um I I believe I even have like all of the evidence
that's been submitted to the court and that's why um that like
it was one of the orders was all of the messages with these people
unedited like in full blah blah blah like those were part of
the requests for discovery. So >> I I understand that it's
a part of the request. I'm asking how do you know that that request
>> Wait, also did Tom just admit to having CESAM himself?
Hold on. Did Tom just admit to having the full archive himself
that he knows has cam in it?
There's no way he just did that, right? >> Was completed
in its entirety. Like, do I I know he's he has stated that he
has to request maybe some of these logs or whatever from Discord,
but how do you know that the requests were actually made and
>> No, no, just no. Just that that you were allowed to
get it and that he got it and that he could surrender it. Like,
I don't I literally don't know. I'm not saying this isn't like
a direct accusation. You're just claiming that you know that
they have all of the logs. So, you know that I do remember why
I got that reason that him and Rose ever sent to each other back
and forth and that he surrendered all of them in its entirety
to the court. You know that for a fact. >> I Yes. I'm saying
that that was that seems to be the case from what from my understanding
is that that is what happened. Um
>> okay. Uh yeah, I I the only reason why I asked is cuz
I don't know what that process is like. I I don't know like I
I don't even know. Can you do that? Can you can I request DMs
from that I have of somebody else that they deleted or maybe
that I deleted from let's say 8 years ago?
I I'm not sure I can do that. >> So at the beginning of
>> I'm not sure this has that >> at the beginning
of the case he was given a court order to retain all messages
that like he was he had to make sure that they that he did not
delete anything in case they requested them. And so that was
like right at the beginning was that like throughout the period
of this case you are not allowed to engage in any spoilage for
these specific things. They gave like names of uh different um
people that he was DMing and then
uh eventually those were in the request for discovery and then
he talked about on stream that like now that we've uh you know
submitted all the DMs they're just digging through all these
>> Tom's final stream on oh he got banned for these logs
or something of Pixie which they're not he got permit from Twitch
for these logs now that we've given everything to them we're
We're just waiting for for this to get dismissed because >> well
you >> but that's >> so just to be just to be clear
right
you you even stated that there was a challenge to Destiny possibly
uh committing spoolie whatever that we're deleting evidence after
>> the case had already begun correct there was an allegation
that he was do yeah so how do you for instance know that he didn't
delete and could not recover evidence prior to the case even
starting Oh, I I don't know that he didn't delete messages. He
could have. Yeah, he may >> Okay. And how do you know he
recovered those deleted messages? >> Um I don't Well, that's
what I'm saying. Hold on. How do I know that he recovered messages
that were saying we don't know if he deleted?
>> No, no, no. How do you know he recovered >> Okay.
Okay. He said, okay, so he used like his like redact.dev
thing to literally delete all of his Discord messages. Like all
of them. literally everything. If you go check your messages
with Destiny, your messages will all have just your messages
left, not his. Um, and so he he literally deleted everything
with everyone. And that's when they accused him of spoliage and
then he went and uh apparently showed them >> uh hold on.
BB Poison says, "What is this code? However severe the punishment
is for violating spoliation is surely not as severe as possessing
seam."
Um, yeah, exactly. And I feel like you could actually like you
do need to you
even if he doesn't want to possess it, he has to inform some
authority to to transfer it to them. Yes. So like dude, I don't
know. There's the the code makes no sense here
in terms of self-interest, in terms of anything following the
law. This code makes no sense in any >> To satisfaction
that he did have everything stored and did not actually engage
in spoliage, just deleted what was on the Discord servers. But
the Pixie team is capable of like requesting
um all of the data from Discord as well. >> Yeah. So so
just my whole point is I don't I generally don't and I'm not
trying to assert this to be the case. I just don't know and nobody
has said to my satisfaction that all >> So to be clear,
Skittles, I think he needs to alert the authorities because he's
in possession of that person that he's just just been informed.
It doesn't matter if he's like pretty sure she's not. I think
like at that point you go, "Oh, I I have to say something now,
right? I have to go talk to the cops. >> All of the logs
in their entirety between Destiny and Rose have been preserved
or recovered and are inside of the case because you're saying
that he has a court order. Court orders don't matter. What matters
is whether or not they were materially recoverable because if
I delete certain messages and they cannot objectively materially
be recovered, then it doesn't matter if I have a court order,
they cannot be >> So the court order isn't relevant
again. Marty Epste going hard in the paint. another five gifted.
Thank you very much, Marty. >> What is relevant is whether
or not he could materially recover those messages and I haven't
seen anything to indicate uh or or go against the fact. I'm just
curious because people have said he surrendered all the messages
and and stuff like that. I just wanted to know if if they had
any evidence that all of them were there, but even beyond that
>> because it sounds like we're just, you know, on different
places on that. What I wanted to ask about was specifically this
because um >> no, you're in feast forever. Uh uh I don't
see >> when I see the flip-flop here and especially how
I've seen other people talk about it. Um I'm just curious genuinely
in your mind how
Destiny could realistically have access to this or very clearly
imply that he has access to this if he spoke to his lawyers about
it. Like it feels like in most situations you probably wouldn't
have access to possible seam if you spoke to your lawyers and
it could be in connection with your case. Right. Um, so, okay.
So, I am going through his case filings right now. I am incorrect.
They have not gotten to discovery yet. They are um they are still
trying to get this dismissed before discovery. So, um >> So,
yeah. So, >> no ligious gamer. I'm almost positive that
even in the PI
I could have sworn there is a like a notice to preserve everything.
Notice to preserve evidence that he got. He didn't get a court
order. He got a notice to preserve evidence. >> I am incorrect
on that. So, yeah. So but they um
they are filings right now. I am in um so okay so I am going
through his case filings right now. I am incorrect. They have
not gotten to discovery yet. They are >> um they are still
trying to get this dismissed before discovery. So um >> Oh
okay. >> So yeah. So I I I am incor >> They're literally
in discovery right now, are they not? I thought they were in
discovery already. >> On that. So yeah. So, but they um
I if I'm a little confused on the >> they are they are
actually sending emails to each other for discovery for information
in discovery. They've been in discovery for a while. No, no,
no. They've been in discovery for a while. >> So, we do
know that he has a court order that says that he isn't allowed
to delete anything regarding these things. Is your >> No,
you generally aren't allowed. And he has a notice to preserve
evidence. That's not I don't believe a notice to preserve evidence
is equivalent to a court order, unless I'm mistaken. or contention
that maybe he deleted it before the court order. >> Yeah,
obviously. Yeah, he's he's deleted like many different things.
If we're talking about that previous thing, yeah, >> Okay.
Yeah. Okay. So, so then if he possibly did that, but now we're
saying >> you're aware that this happened months ago, right?
You think it's possible that really there's like a different
thing that's has that's changed here?
Cuz like this this was happening months ago and he didn't quit
AE. He he like doubled down on on going hard at people. I'm just
saying I think there's probably something else that changed and
that's like some cope
likely >> he does have some of these messages and we're
not thinking that he deleted these
then he would have these messages and is admitting to having
these messages with Rose.
So what is the >> Well, he's he's admitting to having the
videos. He's I didn't see anywhere that he's admitting to having
the messages exclusively like I don't think >> Sure. That's
what I meant like the videos that they were sending him like
>> Yeah, that's that's materally different. I don't think
anybody would Willie Mack or anybody would be upset if he was
like, "Yeah, here's the message showing she her sending me a
link or a download uh uh click for
um a video of her having I don't think Willie Mack would have
been upset. It's that he claims to have copies of the videos.
He's claiming to straight up have sees him,
>> right? But again, so my thought process is he seemingly
from from his DMs and everything, I believe that he thought that
she was over the age of 18. Do you agree with that?
>> You talking about initially? >> Uh, up until recently,
he believed that she was over the age of 18.
>> Um, sure. Yeah, I would say that's probably the case.
Yeah. >> Okay. So,
dude,
>> look at your DMs. >> I would sure he I'm not even
sure even sure. I I think based on his DMs, he just didn't know
and he thought like, "Yeah, there probably are." >> Yeah,
that's what I'm saying is I'm not saying he got enough. As I
said earlier, I my contention is that I don't think he got enough
evidence to reasonably make sure that they were 18, but I'm saying
it at least seems as though he did believe she was over the age
of 18. Uh like he has DMs where he says like this is embarrassing
asking a 19-year-old for uh advice and [__] like
that, right? So like he seems to believe that she's 19. Also,
it's weird that he would try to like get people to find her if
he thought she was underage. It seems weird that he would put
out information to where she would get doxed by Kiwi Farms if
he thought she was underage. Like, there's just a lot of things
to where it seems as though he was of age. So, then when it came
time to where the court orders that he doesn't delete any of
these things, we know that some of the videos are not deleted.
And it seems as though he believes that he has no reason to delete
them because one, he doesn't he didn't at the time think that
she was under 18 at the time of the court order. and two knew
that none of these videos had Pixie in them after October to
where he had no reason to delete any of this and has saved it
to where yes, I just I >> Oh, I just realized I'm like
a couple minutes behind and now that there is a court order cannot
delete these things that now he would have to go through processes
to to delete it to the court. >> No, that's just the problem.
You said that like he has a court order saying he can't he isn't
to delete these things. I'm not sure about that. I don't think
you're sure about that. I know Destiny isn't sure about that
because he contradicted himself in his statement to Willy Mack
where he straight up said, "I don't think that I am." And Willy
Mack made a a literal perfect masterclass point. If you, Tom
Fuller, ever had anything on your computer that you thought had
a chance of being CSM and connected to a court case, would you
immediately talk to your lawyers and get a definitive inclusive
answer as to whether or not you need to have it on your computer?
Probably within the span of 2 hours, would you? The answer is
>> Yes. But the lawyers again, the lawyers may not know
either. It could be again that the lawyers say, "We have to go
talk to the judge about this and we have to find out if
the piece that would be done in 24 hours. Do you disagree?" >> Yeah.
No, Moonray Murray. I know, but I have it sped up. Well, first
of all, first first of all, like it kind of >> It's a weekend,
guys. It's a weekend. I don't know, man. Are there any Is there
anybody else or you could only call your lawyers? You couldn't
maybe call the cops? You don't think the cops might have some
advice here on how to deal with child porn? I think the cops
love hearing about cases of like child porn being spread. They
love going after child predators. Have you heard of the cops?
Your friendly neighborhood police. >> We can. But like,
first of all, that's the beyond the the idea that it would be
done. You could talk to these people. That's literally what they're
paid for. They should know. They went to law school. They would
know. >> Wait. No. No. Hold on. I'm not saying that they
don't know what they're supposed to do. I'm saying they if the
process is they're saying we have to go talk to the law to the
judge first and see if they want if we're okay with deleting
these things. Then yes, Destiny would not know until the judge
gives an answer on what it is he can or can't do in this case.
Not that the lawyers say we don't know what the law is, but that
they don't know what the judge is going to be okay with.
>> No. No. What I'm what I'm saying is not what the judge
is okay with. What I'm saying is that you think
he would know whether or not his lawyers told him specifically
to preserve it or to not preserve it. Sure, it wouldn't be an
I don't think I'm allowed to delete it. Do you agree or disagree
with that? >> Yes, I I agree that >> he would either
know that he's allowed to delete it or not know that he's allowed
to delete it. >> Yes, but I I'm saying that if he says
in this case, I don't know if I'm allowed to delete it, that
that is because he has to check with the judge first. That who
would >> his lawyers would his lawyers would say you cannot
delete this until we check with the judge by that argument even
so even if that is the argument. >> Correct. Then I'm saying
that then therefore would not know if he's allowed to delete
it yet.
>> No, he knows he's not allowed to delete. He his lawyers
told him he can't delete >> the lawyers would literally
say to him, "You cannot delete this until we talk to X, Y, and
Z person. You cannot delete
>> Sure. Yes. I think that Yes. They would probably want
him to hold on to it until they talk to the judge and know what
the judge says. Yes. The lawyers would say until we know what
the judge says.
>> But you're saying you're saying Willie Mack is saying
right now currently you have this and he would know whether or
not he is currently allowed to have it. I'm saying it makes no
sense for him to say I don't know whether I'm allowed to delete
it. He does know his lawyers would tell him. >> Well, he
doesn't say I don't know if he says I think. And we're we're
taking from that that he doesn't know because he says I think.
Right. >> He says I don't think I'm allowed to delete it.
I don't know if it counts as hiding or destroying evidence. >> Yes.
Correct. >> He would know. Well, maybe maybe you would
argue that he would know if it counts as hiding or destroying
evidence, but he would know whether or not he's allowed to delete
it. >> Yeah. Maybe. Yeah. >> Read what I sent you.
It's like a legal
even even if it was a maybe then why does he in one breath say
that he has an obligation to preserve it and then also I don't
think I'm allowed to delete it. >> I don't I don't put
as much weight on the I don't think >> that says it has
to be in in
possession of the government. you cannot possess it. Federal
law >> as you do like I think that generally like lots
of people will will frame things that way when they know something
but they'll still say like yeah I don't think I'm allowed to
delete this. You >> I really really really wish that would
just point out reason to be concerned that she was a minor in
November of 2024. Please
>> I understand why it's like an important part of the
sentence to people.
Bro, there's been allegations since my last video that she was
underage. You still have potential CP of her. I have an obligation
to preserve relevant evidence. So, I created backups of all the
important and relevant conversations. This isn't about conversations.
This is about a video. >> This is not about a conversation.
It's about video. But that's why it matters though is because
it's there's possibilities that the they are saying you have
to
>> uh save communications between you and Rose and like
you know particularly when it comes to like Discord messages
this this and this and >> I think you cut out again for
me. I'm not sure.
>> Yeah, you did. You you stopped that you have to and
then for some reason they didn't come through. Um, it it seems
as though they're saying that he has to collect
all communications between the two of them and then it's possible
that this thing here is was sent to him through some means to
where he doesn't know if this counts as the communications that
he's supposed to save or not and that he's just saved everything
that they ever had between each other. But yes, I I understand
like the I think has a lot of weight on it. >> So, you're
telling me Destiny was told by his lawyers, you're not allowed
to delete this potential CIM or this video. You're not allowed
to delete it. And he just didn't tell Willie Mac. I >> he's
replaced it with I don't think but his lawyer specifically told
him he's not allowed to delete it. >> Yeah. I think I think
that him saying I don't think is is just like to
phrase because he already says I have a court order saying that
I'm not allowed to delete these things. That was my understanding
before he said this before I ever even saw him send these DMs.
I people were already saying bro he has the messages from her
and I'm like yeah he literally had a court order. Don't you guys
remember us all going over this on stream a while back? like
he's literally told he has to retain all communications with
Rose. So like that was already my understanding before he said
this. So him saying I think to me doesn't have a lot of weight
to me because I know that like I went over this. So yeah. >> So
there so even in his breakdown of his point
it's he says I >> Oh I have my alerts off for kick. Oh
uh thank you Cleveland for the raid. Appreciate it. Watching
Relly and Tom debate. right now are relevant. And Tom Fery, it's
uh it's not the best. I I'm literally just trying to see if I
can talk to these guys. I I would love >> I'm pretty sure
I still have an obligation to preserve stuff related to my court
case. I've talked uh about this with my lawyers already specifically
in regards to the road stuff. Why does he keep using I think
these like whatever notions if he is possible on his computer
and he's like I just I I don't know. I >> And he has all
of the logs saved. There's no need to think, right? You don't
need to think. You can go check >> think maybe. I think.
Did he say I talked to my >> clear there was >> yeah
it's in he did the one two three the breakdown or whatever have
him I have it in front >> he said I don't even know 100%
if her age is legitimately under 18 two I'm pretty sure I still
have an obligation to preserve stuff related to my court case
I've talked about this with my lawyer already specifically with
regards to the Rosa so yeah so to me again like when he says
I'm pretty sure that is to in my brain deleted as soon as he
says I've talked to my lawyers about this so like I I know that
there's a lot of weight there because he says it that way in
my head the I'm pretty sure means nothing as soon as he says
I've talked to my lawyers about this um same was like I think
is it like well if we already know there's a court order like
him saying I think this just doesn't mean a whole lot to me but
yeah I >> I in the context of Willie Mac's messages I really
have to Willie Mack is literally saying talk to a a lawyer if
if Willy Mack is like
if two different times been like hey you got to be sure if you
did this talk to your lawyer Destiny is just going to like well
I you're saying Destiny knew he talked to a lawyer specifically
about this and just after getting pressed by Willie Mack was
just like
uh I I'm I'm I'm going to say I'm not sure. I'm pretty sure.
I don't know about I think you're saying he's going to use this
vernacular when Willie Max's like talk to your lawyer. Talk to
your lawyer or talk to a lawyer and then he's just like oh I'm
not sure. I don't know. When he did talk to his lawyer and he
is sure he's using this verbiage.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know why he would use that verbiage
cuz to me it is pretty >> I know exactly why I know exactly
why he didn't talk to his lawyers. Do you disagree? that is very
very ve every single part of these DMs fits perfectly if he did
not talk to his lawyer specifically about this. >> Um well
outside of the fact that he said he's already talked to his lawyer
about
>> Uh or Nick he lied about like how what he was told or
what he thought he it's one of these options, right? There's
no way that he was honest about what he was told about her age
and any suspicions he had or he lied about like what he retained.
I don't know. There's there's something here that's that doesn't
in >> No, it is not. I'm pretty sure I still have an obligation
to preserve stuff related to my court case. And if he hasn't
talked to them specifically about this, it does relate to Rose.
So, it is like um do I delete this? Do I not delete this? I've
talked about this with my lawyer already specifically regards
to the Rose stuff. Okay. So, specifically in regards to the Rose
stuff, he has talked to his lawyer. He has a a a obligation to
preserve stuff to it. Now, is it with this specific stuff like
whether or not he should be holding on to a video that is that
all fits in perfectly?
This is where the pretty sure comes from. Not exactly sure if
I have to hold on to possible seam. >> Oh, you're saying
you're saying not since he found out that she is likely under
18 that she he has not talked to them since then. That's what
you're saying.
that he may have talked to them about this before, but he hasn't
said. >> Say he had reasonable suspicion that she was underage
even prior to this. >> Sure. Okay. But I'm saying you're
saying he has not said to his lawyers, >> I think she's
under 18. What do I do with this? You're saying he has not said
that. Correct. >> Well, I'm saying this fits perfectly
if he hasn't. I don't know what he has or has not done. All I'm
doing is I'm reading the logs and in the logs it pretty clearly
implies that he has not specifically spoken to his lawyers about,
hey, I have reason to believe that this Rose person is underage
and I am in possession of season. What do I
Yeah. Yeah. That that does seem as though he has not told them
that she is under age. Yes. I I I agree that that does fit with
this message. Yeah. >> If if Okay, great. Then if we fit
that in,
then Willie Mack like in his response to this is u maybe not
in its totality. Actually, let's take it away from Willie Mack.
This is abnormal. If you were made aware that very likely you
are in possession of CSM, you would probably within a matter
of minutes, definitely within a matter of hours,
immediately contact your lawyers and then have a consistent thing
for what thing for what you need to do, especially before you
go off and you start talking to people about, hey, yeah, I have
possession of possible CESAP to random content creators inside
of your DM.
>> I don't even have to ask you. I know that that's >> you're
not getting I just want to talk,
Well, again, I don't know that he didn't. We're saying that it
seems that that that would fit with the messages. We don't know
that he didn't do this, but it seems as though that's
>> I mean, it's the most >> like the fun thing to
actually talk about here is like, okay, does he have an obligation
now? Why does he have an obligation now if he's saying that there
is no concrete proof? Or does he just get to hold on to this
until he's like got this person, I guess, until he's got this
person subpoenaed? It's the most reasonable interpretation of
this when somebody's like pressing you on, dude, you need to
talk to your lawyer. Dude, you you're in possession of this stuff.
Dude, you're in possession of this stuff. For him to have a literal
Exodia card, hey, I know you're pressing me for having CP, but
my lawyer said I need to keep on to it. Hold on to it. >> Yeah.
So, is there a possibility? And >> Yes. But is there a
possibility that he >> But is there a possibility that
he did talk to his lawyer, told him that she is under 18 and
that his lawyers say that you you need to hold on to it and he's
saying, "Yeah, I'm pretty sure from what they're telling me,
I have to hold on to this." So that's what I'm doing. >> I
don't I don't think it I don't think it makes sense to speak
this way if he spoke to his lawyers specifically about this.
No, I don't think it's makes sense. When somebody is explicitly
pressing you on talking to a lawyer and you have CP, you're telling
me he spoke to his lawyers and his lawyers said do not delete
that footage and he just doesn't play Exodia. This dude is literally
tanking the damage of holding on to CP
and he you're just like he could play Exodia. My lawyer has told
me to hold on >> play Exodia. I have no I have no idea
>> Sorry. Exodia is it's just a term from like Yu-Gi-Oh.
It's like a card that ends the game. It's like a just a trunk
>> I just win >> anime. So I have >> because
that covers
>> Oh, that's trash, bro. Come on. Don't admit that on
the live, man. Come on. It's Naruto, bro. Come on. >> None
of it.
>> Pokemon. But
>> how do you not know Exodia? How do you not at least
know Exodia? >> Um like, no. Yeah, he he has this get out
of jail free card where he plays it and then all of these allegations
go away. Okay, you have possession of CP or whatever. Your lawyers
said you cannot delete it. There's not really much I can do,
but he's in the Willie Mack video. He's dialing in on these like,
well, I don't know if I don't know. I don't know. And he's pressing
him. >> Well, again, I don't think he's
>> Dude, MTG is pretty sick. I've not >> No, he just
says I think. Which if he if his lawyer's telling him, hey, you're
not allowed to delete this. And he's thinking, damn, if I get
in trouble for this, I'm going to blame my [__] lawyers
for this cuz they're telling >> Dude. Dude. Okay. Okay.
What's the penalty for expoliation? You lose a case or you lose
like what a couple hundred thousand maybe that's the worst possible
penalty. What's the penalty for child?
Federal pound me in the prison,
right?
Like why would you take who what lawyer tells you to take that
risk?
That's crazy. >> When Willie Max says, "Bro, talk to the
lawyer." Why didn't if what you're saying is true, why didn't
Bessie just say I did? Well, he he said a bunch of things and
one of them is him saying, "I've spoken to my lawyers specifically
>> He says he says I'm pretty sure he he does not respond,
I did talk to my unless unless you're saying that Willie Mack
cut something out of this or like it was like deceptively cut
or something." Willy M literally says to him, "Bro, talk to a
lawyer." >> If the take is, >> right? And then he
says, "I don't even know 100% of her age is legitimately under
18 when these were taken. Two, I'm pretty sure I still >> It's
not illegal to not report or submit. Awful though it is." Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Maximus, are you telling me it's not
illegal to possess child and not report or submit it? What >> of
an obligation to preserve stuff related to my court case? I've
talked about this with my lawyer already, specifically with regards
to the Rose stuff. So, it looks like there's a bunch of messages
from Willie Bank. He's responding to each one of them. One of
them is him saying, "I spoke to my lawyers about this." >> He's
about specifically the Rose stuff. And why is he saying, "I'm
pretty sure. Why? Why did I just I did talk to my lawyers. I
cannot delete it." >> I I literally go into this hypothetical
hypothetical. No, that's not that's not an argument. Like, you're
just like, "Oh, I'm pretty sure." So, when you're getting press
>> Oh, sorry, Max. I have no idea why you would say if
he's like a meaningless conversation. Yeah, if he's got somebody
who's 18, he doesn't have to report it. >> on the I don't
know. And he's telling you, go talk to lawyers. You're just
>> like you have to do so many backwards gymnastics with
this guy's uh words and his word games to be able to come to
this conclusion. >> I guess he says hypothetically her
BF or whatever was actually trafficking her or getting her to
other dude on video for him and there was some kind of investigation
to that. Am I hurting any chances of uh any chance of looking
into him by deleting all of this stuff? So >> yeah, he's
saying reason for why he would hold on to it. >> No, there's
no there's like What do you mean? He's Why not just definitively
say my lawyer say I cannot delete it. He's not saying that. He's
saying I'm pretty sure. He's saying I don't think in response
to somebody saying talk to a
>> Yeah. I'm sorry, but we're just reading this very differently.
When you say I'm You're putting a line on the I'm pretty sure,
but he's talking about the obligation there. He does say he's
talked to his lawyer about this already. Specifically with Rose.
>> Yes. Rose stuff. >> No, it isn't. No, it is not.
We are talking about specifically CSAM. That's >> Not the
totality of the Rose. No, no, no. Because when we say talk to
the Rose stuff, there's a million different dimensions where
he obviously can't delete stuff in regards to the conversations
with Rose. It's about whether or not he can delete child that
is possibly on his computer of this other person or if he needs
to possibly surrender it to his attorneys. That's an entirely
different thing. It's not just, hey, it's Rose. And if it was,
he would be answering more confidently. The idea that you could
know for a fact that you
talked to your lawyers for a fact of this specific issue and
then you're telling me this guy who is destiny has said it two
different times in a inconclusive way is insane to me. >> Yeah.
Again
waiting to find out from the court that that is how you would
say it. If you are waiting for your lawyers to find out from
the court on whether or not he's allowed to delete these things.
Uh, Destiny seemed to have backed this up today. Vegeta cooks
seems to have backed it up today. I'm not 100% sure. Or yesterday
rather where he says we Willie asked him about that or maybe
it was in the uh was it in the video. Basically, Willie asks
him about that and I think when Destie goes to respond to maybe
the Ethan piece, Desi responds and says like, "Yeah, when we
were going to look for Rose, I sent this
things and they your lawyers have to come back to you and tell
you whether or not you can get rid of this." That is inconclusive.
You have to wait for the judge to tell you you can delete this
>> Yeah. And he would say that he can't delete it because
that's what he he's saying. Broad talk to lawyer. Just be like,
"Yeah, my lawyer told me I can't delete it." Like this is I feel
like for for the sake if we're if we were talking about maybe
some random guy, that'd be fine. We're talking about Destiny.
This guy who takes super seriously, deletes messages with all
these different people, has like backups of backups, records
private conversations with people, but he doesn't know how to
like do this. He doesn't know how to
speak clearly when he's getting pressed on having CP. >> Well,
he did already say that there is a court order saying that he's
not allowed to delete messages. Willie Max says, "But it's CP."
And so he says, "Yeah, I've like I I'm pretty sure I still have
an obligation to retain these things." So from that perspective,
if he did talk to his lawyers about it and they do have to check
with the courts, he's already said, "I have a court order, but
like I'm pretty sure I still have to retain it." They're finding
out like that all fits with what it is that I'm saying. I'm not
saying that you're wrong and I'm not saying that I'm denying
anything that you're saying, but >> I just this is like
actually like so pointless. It's like what what you actually
need to know is when you have suspicion that it is child, when
somebody tells you it's child porn, do you have any reason at
all if you don't know at that point and somebody tells you, the
person you say produced this tells you, do you not have some
kind of obligation then? But I am saying that you seem to totally
discount the possibility of the fact that they are waiting for
the courts to come back and give them the information. And I'm
not >> I'm not discounting that fact. I'm not discounting
that fact. What I'm discounting is that he specifically talked
to his lawyers about this [__] There's two realities.
Either he he literally lost like 30 IQ points and then totally
forgot how to defend himself or he uh is didn't talk to his lawyers
specifically about this chick possibly being underage because
his >> I'm waiting for my lawyers to tell me one to one.
You're saying he would say my lawyers tell me delete it? >> Nope.
Very simple. My lawyers told me not to delete it until they spoke
to the judge. That easy,
>> Is it not that easy? It's that easy. >> Yeah,
sure. Yeah. >> Okay. And so he just decided to not do that
and instead he knew that that's what his lawyers told him, but
he was just like, I don't know. I don't think I don't know when
he's specifically getting pressed on it. Like that's I understand
we're going to have like a material disagreement on like that
specific line, but like to me that feel it feels so incredibly
obvious. You need to do no leaps. There's no leaps. there's no
anything that needs to be done with the idea. He just didn't
talk to his lawyers about specifically this. He hasn't talked
to his lawyers specifically about it um in regards to this. Uh
>> why wouldn't he though why wouldn't he tell his lawyers
though? Because like I understand the thought process of like
where a bunch of people are saying he should go tell the cops
and he should turn it into the cops. Like I understand why he
wouldn't go call the cops or call the FBI and get himself in
trouble.
>> There's not even any indication they went to the court
about this. Lol. This is all fanfiction. I mean we'll have to
dude we'll have to talk to his lawyer. >> Yes. I think
he would talk to his lawyers like immediately. Like that's what
I would do. That's what any person would do. Like even if they
think they might get in trouble for it, they would go talk to
their [__] lawyers about it. So to me, there's just
almost no reason or explanation to say why he wouldn't talk to
his lawyers. I >> guys, it's just the smart thing to do
would just be to go talk to his lawyers, guys, and tell them
the exact truth. That would be the smart thing to do. Why wouldn't
Destiny do the smart thing to >> But I agree that like
based on the language here, there's like a reasonable um idea
that he didn't talk to his lawyers. To me, that's just almost
too stupid. That's almost too stupid because they're literally
the only p people in the world you would talk to about this.
>> no. I I think it could make sense
>> Oh, here we go. Here's the super chat. Destiny was told
last November by the creator and distributor of the Cam that
Rose was a minor, so he's been waiting for an answer for 9 months.
Lol.
>> We say what we would do in these situations because
we are like truly innocent of this situation. I imagine if you
actually thought that there was a chance not only were you in
possession of CISM, but also you had potentially sent uh uh videos
of yourself or other people to a minor. Lord knows what he if
he might have sent the videos that she sent to him to other people.
He could be absolutely deep fried. We don't know. He could be
deep fried, right? Because if he sent these videos of Rose to
other people, he's cooked. All right, that is >> right.
But I'm saying even if that's the case, he would it would still
be his lawyers that he would speak to about it, right? like outside
of the fact that he would be embarrassed of it or something.
It would still be his voice who he would tell about this. Is
>> he intentionally talking over the >> I don't know
and maybe he does. I don't know the exact uh attorney client
privilege. I don't know what the likelihood of this potentially
getting uh uh blown up into a further legal matter. I don't know
if he thinks that if he discloses this to his lawyers that that
means that they then have an ethical obligation to disclose this
to the court and now this becomes a criminal case. Whereas otherwise
if he didn't disclose it to his lawyers, they don't have an ethical
obligation to do this. I I like I I literally don't know because
there's
no possibility of that. I I think that's like >> you see
no possibility that if if Destiny told his lawyers, I believe
I'm in possession of CISAM that there is no ethical obligation
that those lawyers would have to potentially present that inside
of a a either this case or some kind of other legal case. You
don't see that there would be a potential
to go to the cops. Like if they're literally supposed to keep
confidentiality on murders and defending and [__]
like that, there's almost >> no no no no no no no no no.
Uh possessing CSAM is a crime. You cannot you cannot counsel
somebody to commit a crime, right? That's the difference. If
you murdered somebody, you tell them I think facts of the case.
I don't know what exactly happens there if there's no threat
to anybody, but you're not actively committing a crime, right?
The problem with holding CESAM is you are actively committing
a crime by possibility that they would ever be incriminate for
crimes.
>> Just to be clear, lawyers don't have lawyers of the
the um what you call it the attorney client privilege isn't immune.
You aren't immune to all disclosure for attorney client privilege.
I don't know what the bounds of attorney client privilege are,
but I know there are bounds. There are certain things that where
if you tell a lawyer, they are ethically obligated to tell the
court or surrender information to the court if they believe it
to be the case. I don't know if he's going to or not.
>> Um yeah, that's not my understanding. I mean, I I've
been involved in numerous like criminal cases that uh that I
was in trouble for and I would talk to >> clients intended
or ongoing crimes primarily under Yes. Yes. Yes. >> This
is what I did. This is what I said. And they're like, "Okay,
well, I think we can get all this dropped. Don't worry. We're
only going to talk about this part, this part, this part. So,
just follow my lead." Like that's uh it just seems um but I just
looked it up. Yes. Lawyers have a limited ethical obligation
that discloses information about a client's intended or ongoing
crimes primary. Yes. So, if that is true. Yes. If they say that
they're going to go kill somebody or they're going to go like
harm a child or something like that, then yes, in those cases,
yes, they they do have an ethical obligation. But not >> even
still with like so for instance
>> possessing child board is a crime in the state of Florida.
>> Uh so all I'm saying is neither one of us being lawy
there was the the individuals that have spoke about similar cases
and stuff like that, but there was also the guy who spoke specifically
about this case who the legal mindset dude be how you may about
that guy. right? A lot of people have different feelings about
him, but he spoke about this in a manner that was like, "Hey,
may maybe there would be an obligation for his lawyers to be
able to disclose these things as a matter of fact if they were
made aware of it."
Um, I don't know. Um, maybe that would be the reason why Destiny
would be hesitant to do this. But even if we assume that he's
totally in the grain and totally like there is no blowback he
could get for disclosing this to the lawyers, then uh at the
end of the day, I don't see why he would in a conversation with
another person say that he doesn't know what if he has to hold
on to CP
because he's explicitly getting pressed on it. I would the the
idea that all of his self-preservation, all of his knowledge
of how to have a conversation, all of his ability to read how
a conversation is going flew entirely uh out of his ears the
moment that he had a conversation with Willie Mack and he got
pressed on whether or not he should be holding on to CP.
Especially when he was directly he told, "Hey, bro, go talk to
a lawyer." And you're saying he knew he talked to a lawyer. You're
saying he knew that this lawyer told him, "Do not delete it until
we uh talk to a judge and this was his response." I don't think
so. >> Well, to me, the the conversation right now isn't
even just as much about whether or not he ought to have it right
now, but whether or not he is allowed to have it at all ever.
And I think
>> it's a great question watching you back. like I if that
that seems to be what the conversation is about and he's saying
I don't know right now like he he he's finding out from the judge
if he is supposed to still have this if he is still supposed
to be uh retaining all of this information and if they're allowed
to delete it at all but then he's saying even if they come back
and say that I have to delete this or or that I don't have to
retain this I would still want to keep it for a future case with
this uh other solo guy and that but he does say that it's not
on his computer and that he doesn't have it. So to me, this is
like a >> I'm sorry. >> Yeah, go ahead. >> I
I'm sorry because what even what you just read attorney client
privilege doesn't like extend to ongoing crimes. Wouldn't just
having C sees him be an ongoing crime >> in a in somewhat
of a >> Yes. So, it's an ongoing crime, but it's not a
uh it's not one that is like currently
uh harming somebody outside of the fact that like yes, having
CSAM.
Okay. Well, hold on. Hold on. Florida mandatory reporting law.
Florida statutes require any person in the state who knows or
has reasonable cause to suspect that a child is abused, including
abuse or exploitation, to report it to the Department of So,
would this count for CSAM? So, I I asked basically here's what
I asked. Okay. In the state of Florida, if I sent videos and
was then informed by someone that it was seam, am I required
to report it to an authority? What if I suspect the person who
informed me that the content is CSAM of lying? What if I suspect
I I uh is lying, I guess. But
uh what if you suspect the claim is false? If you genuinely have
no reason to believe the content involves a minor and the and
the allegation appears unfounded or malicious, you likely do
not have the reasonable cause that triggers. However, the standard
is very low. If a reasonable person your position would think
it might be CSAM, you should report it. Okay. Uh failing to report
when you have reasonable cause can be a thirdderee felony.
Up to 5 years in prison and a $5,000 fine. Even if you think
the tip is false, if the material does depict a minor, possession
itself is a serious crime under Florida law and federal law.
Oh well, Chat GPT is, you know, pretty good as a lawyer. A lot
of times it's it's not necessarily, but I think in direct interpretations
of statutes it can be. Okay. And I trust I I feel like I trust
it almost as much as Legal >> of somebody who like obviously
viewing it is harm, but I don't think it's the same as like going
and taking pictures of somebody in the same way that uh we're
talking about. >> I don't think it has to be. I think it
it's just an ongoing crime. No, >> we can look up. >> The
question is whether or not attorney client privilege has a stem
ongoing crime, but something that is immediate harm to another
person after thereof. Correct. From this point forward, correct?
But we we don't know. We're going to need one of it is an ongoing
>> I think we do know. I think it's obvious that like if
somebody gets in trouble for having the and that lawyers are
defending them on it that the whole their lawyers are not just
going to come out and be like yes they do have this and they
are underage and they serve you I have to uh I have to say all
of this like I don't think they're going to do
>> No you you do you think that's what I do you think that's
what I think because I know you don't >> he's not being
he's not in court he's not in any criminal court for the for
possessing this stuff. That's not what he's in court for. They
don't have to not report it. I >> think that's what I think.
So I don't >> that is what I collect from the argument
that you just made. So if you want to hit every word, >> the
argument I'm making is very basic. When you >> and unfortunately
for Tom, Destiny has signed an affidavit
in this case that says he's already sent to this person >> undergoing
an ongoing crime. The uh the lawyers that you have have an obligation
to stop if whatever if you're being litigated for it, stop that
ongoing crime and surrender relevant evidence to the authorities
for litigation. So in the case of possession of CIS Sam, I would
be willing to bet I I'm not a lawyer, but I'd be willing to bet
if you have CP on your hard drive, they don't just go, "Yeah,
you know, just go ahead and hold on to that one for me, bud."
What they do is they're going to take it from you, put it on
some kind of secure drive instead of a secure facility and then
surrender it to the authorities or whoever relevant. That's what
they're going to do. >> Yes. But currently this is not
a CESAM case. This is not he is not as far as >> it is
not a cam case but it is an ongoing crime to be in possession
of
>> Correct. But again you're saying that when he's not
being investigated for CESAM that you think they have an obligation
to go and disclose to the authorities that he has seam. >> I
never I never said that. I what I said was I believe that Destiny
could have been reasonably in fear that if he were to disclose
to his lawyers that he is currently in um engaged in an ongoing
crime of being in possession of CISAM that he would be worried
that this could now turn into a criminal case. >> Okay.
So you're not saying they do have this ethical responsibility
but that Destiny could be in fear of them having
>> No, they almost certainly have this ethical responsibility.
>> Ethical responsibility. >> Yes. And that would
that would cause him >> I could even believe that it's
even just embarrassing. Like even even just like the human aspect
of like obviously the lawyers are the people that you would tell
when you say like you know oh we all say we would do this thing.
My first thought is it also could be just embarrassing as [__]
to try to even admit this even to your own lawyers that this
is uh something that you ended up with. So I can totally I can
totally imagine that. Uh >> sure. Sure. >> So I I
think there are realities where in which this happens to him.
He just doesn't immediately hand it over to authorities or sorry
the his lawyers his lawyers. Um, I think there are realities
where that happens. But most importantly, I don't see why you
would ever speak in this manner if you know for a fact you are
legally allowed to hold on to this. If somebody pressing you
on the legality and the eth the ethical nature of holding on
to this, you don't just say, "My hands are tied. My lawyers told
me not to delete it." Um, this feels like super 101, super basic,
super super big. I would expect a Darius IRL to have this response,
let alone Destiny. Um, >> yeah, I just I just don't think
so. And even on top of that, the idea to me that like this is
so public right now that he knows that everybody in court likely
will find out about this because Pixie knows about this and other
people who are part of the case know about this. Like the court
will >> I don't I don't think Pixie knows I don't think
Pixie knows he has a videos of Rose saved on her his computer.
>> No, no, no. Pixie if she Okay, so if Pixie knows that
all of the DMs with Rose is supposed to be retained and that
he traded nudes with her and that some of those nudes were of
a minor that that was going to come out anyways. So whether or
not whether or not he again whether or not he has >> it
seems
uh so I ask chat Gvt it seems to say that the attorney is likely
not obligated to report it. Okay. Because it's protected >> on
his own computer or if he literally just has like a a cloud storage
file that him and his lawyers trade uh evidence through and send
information through and [__] like that that like
she still knows he like had. >> Dude, it's still illegal
in the state of Florida for anybody in the state of Florida to
possess child. It's only legal for the government. Okay. like
they they don't [__] around with this >> traded
images with a minor.
>> That doesn't mean it will be surrendered. He could have
deleted them and then the court would have in theory never known
because there would be no >> um I I don't think well kind
of yeah I guess I think that he's already admitted >> Let's
say you send me a picture of your right now and I have a reason
to believe that we're going to get into a court case later about
how I I'm wanking it to a picture of your and I just delete it
6 months before the case and Discord won't let me recover it.
I never got a picture of that dude. I don't know what you're
talking about. >> Yeah, unless you already wrote like a
document saying that you like
traded nudes and and talked about this on your stream. And >> yeah,
that's that's that's fair enough. But like there is if there
is no like uh hard evidence that you had this saved on your computer,
done any of these things, then you could get off on a significantly
lesser charge. Oh, >> yes. But again, if he's already said
to the courts when they accuse him of spoilage that I have already
collected all of these DMs and everything on a hard drive, I
have all these on USBs and everything. Everything is collected
and preserved that the I don't know how he >> It will just
be your pay.
>> Hold on. >> Eers one donated $5. Did you see this?
>> I don't know. Hold on. Uh
why is that getting cut off? Oh, cuz the link's so big. Well,
we'll see. >> You're assuming that he told the court or
that he will surrender the court the images or videos that he
has of this person a part of this case as a part of this case?
>> I he could have deleted this before the case even began.
>> Yes, he could have. Yes. True. Okay.
So, I I don't know. I'm sure I'm sure he talked to his lawyer.
>> Anyone uh because of the the thing
uh because of the connection through Dan is how they they see
it is like they were connected
>> a great many things and stuff like that. Um I was just
saw uh some of your your thoughts on some of the things. >> Try
not to link like
>> people in connection to this. Um I another thing that
I guess I was curious about kind of in connection to this uh
for for your opinion was how how uh confident are you that she
is actually uh underage and that they got the right person when
they were going through the things and [__] like
that. How confident are you that that is the right person and
that she is underage or she was
>> Very confident.
>> Very very confident. The reason So I'll just explain
my reasoning for that confidence. Um >> the post that was
put out. So this is one of the things that like JCK was kind
of being dishonest about is he was talking about the fact that
Destiny posted an image of this girl who's only wearing nothing
but DGG merch. That's it. She's just wearing this like little
DGG shirt and nothing else. The image is like it's like a dress.
like the shirt
comes down to like her knees. It's not this like very revealing
image of her, but in that image is her face. And the video of
her on the news
uh
on the uh news um interview is also the same face. Like it is
the same it is the same >> First time.
>> Okay. Why did he Did he just say that cuz he knows I'm
watching? >> Um, okay. Wait,
>> what was this honest? I think I even said like I wouldn't
say it's like erotic, but like it is just her wearing a shirt.
It's like a girl wearing your big shirt, right? Like that's the
whole >> Okay. Because he said Jtock you felt like Jtock
was dishonest about that,
>> Yeah. The way he was Yeah. The way he was making it
sound like he's posting like these LWD images of her, but it's
it's her in a shirt. >> Okay. So, you don't believe that
was a lewd image?
>> Okay. So, would you feel comfortable having a picture
of a 17-year-old girl you're not related to on your computer
that looked the same as that? >> The same as that? Yeah,
sure. Or like on the internet, like on normal like >> To
be clear, I I haven't seen I haven't seen the >> Don't
get him on my No,
>> I'll just
Yeah. So, just to be clear, >> that's not dispositive of
it being >> Uh when I was telling everybody this isn't
a loot image. I don't know why he said this. I started saying
here, I'll show you guys. And my chat starts freaking out. No,
Tom, don't pull it up. Don't pull it up. I pulled it up on my
screen and they were all immediately like, "Oh, oh, wait. Yeah,
there's nothing sexy about that at all. What the
They were all freaking out and then immediately nobody had a
problem with the image because Yes. It's just not >> I
think when somebody's just wearing only your shirt when that's
the only thing you'd see them wearing. I think that's just a
little odd. I just I'm
>> I'm sorry.
>> It's It's It's fair enough. >> But initially,
you asked about her confident I was about the age and it sounded
like you were about to ask something else after that. Yeah. Yeah.
So, um from that with that knowledge, um
is there like what do you think I'm not saying for like
and I totally understand if you're just like, "Hey, I don't I
don't know what the legal process is. I don't I don't know."
Whatever. What do you think is the likelihood or l lack thereof
that this is like a pretty serious situation for
>> because based on my heat check it seems like there's
actually a possibility he could face federal time or like actual
prison time for this. >> I I so federal I'm not sure. So
the problem is is that like in the DMs with the Twitter DMs that
it does seem as though there's a possibility that he that she
sends a uh some sort of like ID or something like that. It does.
I have no idea, but like it seems like a possibility, but for
Florida, >> is it a possibility? >> That doesn't
matter. Like for Florida, it they would not give a [__]
about that. For or sorry,
may maybe I have this backwards, but anyways, I I went over like
a >> also why is he and >> why is he just taking
the Twitter DMs as >> It's just not going to matter like
one way or the other. And that uh >> waiting room coming
on. Oh god.
could be like depending on how they can like even get the
uh data and I assume you're able to get data from Twitter the
same way that you can get it from Discord and all that. So I
I would assume that they're able to get the rest of those DMs
and yeah, it seems
it seems bad. >> Does Lab have an FBI outfit? I believe
she does. Hold on. >> I was just This is pretty crazy because
this doesn't even this isn't even like drama really. This is
like coming in to >> like true crime at this point. >> They
say how crazy it is that >> Well, I mean that's you know
>> you know >> that bad things happen to my enemies.
>> You know it's it's crazy
>> Yeah. It's it's crazy that you know day after day, you
know, things pass and
and I prosper
and uh my enemies turn to >> It's always a good feeling.
>> Uh do you want to hear my real take? You might hate
it.
>> Um, on the rose thing. Yeah, I don't think I'm going
to hate it. We'll see. It's probably what I would expect. Go
>> Um, I mean, I think I have the I I have the max take,
which is I don't think he's a but obviously this is like him
being like really uh stupid. I don't think that this will affect
him in any way, but um I think it does show that he's like out
of control and not not in like a oh my god, he's such a gooner
way, but in like a >> I mean I would say any argument you
could make over the age like realistically her being 17 and 1/2
versus 18 and 1/2 in terms of like rationalizing how weird it
is for him to be in that relationship. I'm not sure there's a
massive difference, but obviously in terms of the law and legally
under like having somebody there's a there is literally all of
the difference in the world. There's Well, I think there's enough
space to where he
I think if she did was like lying, he's like not really especially
in states like uh
like Florida.
>> there's there's not I don't think that he'll end up
actually being in that I don't think he'll end up being that
much trouble. If this were Wisconsin, he'd get the book thrown
at him, but it's just not >> Wait, do you know what the
statutes are in Florida or you just saying off of the Florida
vibes? I don't think you'll get in trouble.
>> Uh well, both. I I think that from everything that I've
read online.
>> Yeah. From everything that Well, I don't know the statutes
like by heart and I >> read something about them. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I know. I know what I know what the streets are saying.
I know what the streets are saying. >> Okay. That's not
the same thing, but All
>> My opinion that guy Jesus. Sorry. The Rampage Jackson
Sun thing. I don't know if you saw that.
Definitely not play that clip on stream. >> Yeah. Well,
obviously it's literally somebody dying. >> Well, he's
awake now, but uh >> Oh, I thought Hold on. No, no, no.
The tweet I saw, they said they the guy got >> No, he woke
up. >> Oh, okay. Maybe they just [__] with
him. I could have >> he flatlined. He flatlined was the
last thing I heard. That was the last thing I heard, too. >> No,
that was the that's what the the guy said. Like his manager said
that, but I think it was like a holy, I can't believe you just
did that sort of thing. I don't think it was like real. >> Oh,
I see. He said he was told. Okay. All right. Lab's boyfriend
is a white supremacist. Wait until you hear about Lab's thoughts.
>> Neither of us are white supremacists.
We just We're just noticers. We're just >> Yeah, just notice
patterns. Yeah, I got >> We just We're just noticers. >> Guys,
five subs away from another hour on the stream. We're going to
continue on with this Tom Fury rally debate. Okay, we're going
to do it. >> It's so hard to feel support, but yeah, I
I don't I really don't think that uh Steven will get in in trouble
for this and and like I said, if it was a different state, maybe,
but I I just don't see it happening. I just don't see it. I I
genuinely think that he'll walk away from like most of everything
completely unscathed. >> And not for not because I want
him to, just because I think that this is like how [__]
works cuz he has enough money. >> Um I mean, we'll see.
We'll see. We'll see. We'll see.
>> Yep. Hold on. What was that? Marty Epste with five.
Oh, Marty Epste going for another hour. We love Marty Epste here,
guys. Marty Epste carrying the stream, carrying monetization.
Let's go. >> What's the Tom Foolery stuff? Like, is he
still relevant? How many how many viewers is he getting a stream?
>> He got a he's got 100 right now, but he's uh he's doing
the Destiny thing. Okay. He's been overtaken by food shops as
Destiny's number one uh like favorite vendor. Uh >> that
is crazy how the mighty have
Yeah, Tom, too. >> What are Can I get a pulse check on
how everyone feels about Willie Mack now?
>> Uh, literally exactly the same as >> Just that
what he's like a >> It's funny that I guess he gets points
for like doing the video that like actually made Destiny crack
and start admitting really things. >> I'll give I'll give
him that. >> But he's still like a totally worthless loser.
So, >> he came off as really disingenuous in that short
little video. I maybe I'm get maybe that's just vi bad vibes.
I don't know. I'm a vibe based uh person. >> I don't know
why you would be like I'm going to report this guy for child
and then immediately post a video about it to the internet. Like
wouldn't you want to give the cops sometimes to some time to
do some things or no? You just want to post that video as soon
as you can or >> Yeah. Is Destiny still memeing his way
through it? >> Oh yeah. Yeah. He played uh Max's I'm a
song to start a stream today, you know. >> That's awesome.
Have you can you think of somebody who's memed through the allegations
like effectively?
>> Women don't count. All women are m natural. So you guys
get a pass. >> Keemstar Dr. Disrespect. Yeah. >> I
don't know if I don't know if Keem went through it. >> Bosch
was not actually caught with a kid of any kind, right? He was
caught with drawings of kids.
>> No. No. They were short stack goblins.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Actually, he kind of did just get
caught grooming a kid. So Vos is somehow Vos is skating in Destiny's
wake. Okay, Destiny's like literally making the wake. And Vos
is like the dolphin behind the shipping thing. He's just like
chilling. He's like, "Okay, as long as this guy keeps doing worse
than me, I'm good. I'm chill. Please, Destiny, don't go down
yet. Please, please, please let those DMs go through people's
mind and out the other side. Okay,
>> all this stuff is so crazy. It's so It's so crazy that
like I you know I've been not really like online that much except
for like you know around my husband's streams and I'm like I
feel like I'm like you know certified grass toucher now. I feel
like if I were to tell any normal person about any of the Destiny
drama, they'd be like what the is going on with that guy? Like
what? He's always doing something wacky.
>> Uh-huh. He's He's like, "Did you >> just get into
a whole drama where you guys were trading texts about your your
husband, another streamer's girlfriend, and then it like blew
up an entire >> I just told I literally I literally just
told you except for my husband's stuff. I literally just said
Did you hear me
>> No. No. >> I literally just said I'm >> Yeah.
No, I I didn't I didn't listen to that or hear it. I'm I'm just
going to be honest with you. Okay. I'm trying to do that now.
Radical honesty. I was not >> Yeah. You're like sometime
you literally are sometimes just like the guy who gives push
back. You know that? >> Uh no. I was just like sometimes
you're like you're like the guy who like you're just like you're
like you're just a presser. You're just like the the guy who
gives >> I have like a critical thought process. I'm trying
to work on it. Okay. >> Yeah, that is not critical. You
just you didn't hear anything I said. >> No, I was critical
of the things I heard you say. >> Interesting.
Um I would like to I would like to also say that he's now saying
that I' I've him >> uh your husband. >> No, Destiny.
My third >> saying that for a long time. >> Yeah,
he's been saying that for a long >> Yeah, I just I just
heard him like say it for the first time though. I didn't This
is like the narrative now is that
chat. Can we get a pulse rate on that? Am I right? Do you guys
believe him? >> You are. Yes.
I ch
>> We're getting a lot of yeses here. We're getting a lot
of yeses. There's not a lot of nos. There's a lot of yeses. >> Holy
cow. Not a single three. >> Yes. physical and spiritual.
>> that I think I think that he ripped me cuz I didn't
know what his penis looked like when we hooked up. And I feel
like I think that >> Dude, I I kind of wanted to stop talking
about that, but
>> there was like a hypothetical like are you more Yeah.
Yeah. I don't think so. I also, you know, I think back I think
back and I say I asked him if he'd ever hooked up with a guy
before because if he had ever hooked up with a guy, I did not
want to like meet up with him and he had told me that he had
not yet. I think he was lying >> which I actually which
I actually do think is kind of a it's a little
>> No, I could I could do the hypothetical. I just think
it's wrong.
I think I think No. I think No. >> I don't know. I I at
least think that's >> lying. Definitely lying. It's definitely
>> Yeah, but it's it's it's lying to to
snooze. So, I think that that's um I think that is sort of a
a low tier. >> Yeah, I don't know about that.
>> I mean, charges, >> but it is >> it's certainly
immoral. It's certainly immoral. He might have thought you weren't
serious, though. There are some things that it's like >> it
depends on how reasonable it would be for them to think uh you
would say no if you knew, right? If he knew that Lav wouldn't
do it, if he had slept with a man, then it's at least essay.
That's what I'm saying. It's like a It's like a low tier essay.
>> No, I think back to saying that they No, we did not
have
>> No, we did not have a >> reasonable person could
think you were joking there. I think if he had AIDS, okay, if
somebody had AIDS and they you lied about >> Well, he probably
Well, he had first of all, a lot of times you don't find out
that you have AIDS until like eight months later, like it's dormant.
So if >> how much TRT your husband does those breasts he
has are definitely googling >> um people talk about your
husband's breasts being rich rich in estrogen. That's [__]
weird.
>> That was a weird dono. That was a weird dono. That was
a weird weird dono. >> I wish he had estrogenic breasts.
No, I I do feel a little uncomfortable about it. I mean I I would
never like uh I I don't think it actually is a I don't know if
I'd call it that, but I think um it did make me feel weird when
I saw him like that. you know, the leaks came out of him sucking
dick and it was around the same time I was like, "Oh, I like
literally told him that I would not meet up with him if this
happened." And I don't know the timeline, but it it did make
me feel violated for sure. Call me homophobic. Call me homophobic.
You kissed him on the I don't I don't think that I don't think
I kissed I don't remember if I kissed him. I >> think we
don't need a We don't need a review of the situation. >> Maybe
I did. I actually don't remember. >> It's gross. Did you
see the Tom picture? Did I send that to you? Hold on. I did
the the Tom the Tom avatar. If we ever get Tom on the stream,
we got a avatar lined up. >> Where are you sending it?
>> Are you I'm not getting anything. Are you sending it
to the account that I'm on right now or my old account that got
>> Oh, your old account that got nuked.
>> GG.
Why do you get banned so much? >> Uh, I got I actually
got banned for for reposting his DMs with the the the teenager.
Oh god, that is not good. That makes him look really bad. I don't
Why is Is Tom thinking that this is like
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Is it inaccurate or is it
>> No, he's just ugly. So that it's like it's realistic.
>> He's just skinny. He's like too skinny. >> He
looks like he would [__] teenagers, which I'm sure
is why he uh is chilling >> Hold on. >> Destiny,
they should move to Israel. >> Didn't we have a clip about
Tom and 17year-olds last night?
>> Oh god. >> I don't see it. Unfortunate. I thought
we had a clip about Tom and 17year-olds last night, but
let me try to find it. Is he still dating that one girl?
>> Uh, yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> They're a
match made in hell. >> Tom is a very symmetrical face.
That's >> Oh god. You're going to you're going to let her
talk to you like that?
>> You're going to let your lady talk about other men like
that? >> Yeah. She's like basically she's basically like
totally
>> She's she's basically like totally facelind. You said
once that uh Walter from Fresh and Fit was conventionally
>> I have no idea. Is Walter the shorter black one? >> His
name's Walter.
>> There's actually no way. Hold on.
>> Walter.
Gohead. Go ahead and Google him. Go ahead and Google him.
>> What the [__] This is the one that got that
Asian girl pregnant.
>> Did she end up having it? Do we know? >> No, it
was fake. Oh, no. She got an abortion. It was an abortion. She
got an >> That's sad. Well, that's pretty good though.
Obviously, you know my thoughts. >> The purgatory is kind
of [__] up when you think about it. >> He looks
like you know what? I won't even say it.
>> Wow, that is crazy. I Jerry, you're thinking this guy's
handsome.
>> She said conventionally attractive. >> There ain't
no way. >> I think she thinks that like conventionally
attractive means facial symmetry, but I'm not totally sure. I
think she thinks it means facial symmetry, but even if the facial
features are really bad,
that conventionally attractive means facial symmetry.
I >> I guess that that I mean, yeah, I guess like he's
Yeah, I guess he's I don't Why is his brow bone has like fat
on it? How How is that happening?
>> I don't know. >> That's crazy. He has diabetes
for sure. >> I'm actually conventionally attractive and
I I I just know that from past experiences. Okay. I just know
that. >> Oh, you get a lot of women, do you?
>> Face reveal when
you point. >> At some point. >> Are you going to
do like the dream thing where you have to like lose 200 lb
>> before you >> come on camera?
>> What are you like building up muscle in the gym? You're
getting your >> No, I'm like probably actually getting
fat right now to tell you the truth. >> A good woman will
do that. A good woman will do that. Yeah, she's been making
>> Oh, that's cute. >> I've all this time I've been
telling you that you need to find a wife.
>> All I need to fix my life was to take Lav's advice.
That's all I had to do to fix my entire life. >> That's
all That's all anyone needs to do. That's all anyone needs to
do. Genuinely, you seem happier. You seem like a little more
uh you know. Oh, dude. I tried to get through your video on the
Destiny stuff. You got to You got to turn your squeal down by
like 20%. You're a squealer. You know that? >> By like
by like 20%. Just so you know, you're like listenable in a VOD.
Love you. But holy cow. >> Nope. You're wrong. >> Your
whole audience. >> You're wrong.
>> I don't know. >> All these people. All these people
sitting here watching. All these people sitting here watching.
>> I think they're siding with me. One's in chat. If you
think you should turn it down 20%.
>> You just win cuz I talk about them constantly. So they
don't like me. They're ready to take the side of anybody who
joins at all times. >> Maybe. Maybe they'd like you more
if you turn that into the squeal 20%.
>> Which one? Hold on. Are you talking about the one I
just did or a different
>> What do you mean? >> I just asked you >> like
your voice. Like when you're going to You're like,
>> "No, you're wrong. >> Try to talk. Try to talk
like a like a normal person. Talk like this.
Let's do a couple of exercises." >> No, it sounds pretty.
No, that sounds pretty good. >> I believe in you. I think
you could do >> I uh I mocked your husband when he suggested
the same. I'm like, "Oh, yeah. I could be like a total and I
could just do the radio voice. I could do the radio voice. Guys,
don't you want to talk about Tom Foolery and all relevant talking
to each other? So much better legal obligations that they have
uh when they possess Seam. Tom Foolery of course being an expert
in Seam possession.
that's so funny. I love that. I have my husband talking baby
talk to me too on stream. It's brutal. >> It's so brutal.
It's so brutal.
Just I think that that actually sounds a lot better. I think
that you should try to do that. It's It is way less shrew. >> No,
it's gay. It's not my voice. >> I I think your voice right
now is gay.
>> I'm saying that as a friend. >> Thank you. Gay
people very successful. >> You don't like baby talking.
>> I can't be
>> I'm I can't be. So being a little gay might help me
out. Okay. In show biz. >> She's right. Dude, you're the
people have spoken. >> I am so secure in this that I'm
I'm like totally fine. I think well I think you um I think you
call in a specific audience which is um gay men. >> That
would be awesome. >> What do you think? What is your is
your audience um like liberal or conservative? Sorry, I'm like
completely derailing. I'll leave soon. I have a couple questions.
Are they more liberal than they are conservative?
>> Interesting. Well, you're a conservative though, aren't
you? Or more
>> Uh I kind of was until Trump kind of all over the planet.
Yeah. I I like had
he's more liberal than >> Jesus Christ. I No, the tariffs
and stuff. I was just like, "Okay, we need a >> we need
to eat the bugs right now." >> One man can make you liberal.
Holy >> uh one man can make me want to eat the bugs. And
it's the guy who decided he's going to try to destroy the world
economy. Yeah. >> Yep. Yep. Basically, >> you know,
there are other Republicans. >> Yeah. What do they do?
They suck that guy's car. >> They hang out with your They
hang out with their friends and family. Kind of gross. Kind of
gross. >> I used to be the governor of Utah. Yeah, I guess
it is kind of gay. Okay. Well,
yeah, just fun to fun to hang out again. And uh also, I'm always
right. That's that's what I will say. And everything I've ever
said, Listen, I've never been wrong. I've just been too early.
Remember that. >> Nope. Nope. That's what people who say
that's what people say when they're >> Nope. That's actually
Name one thing I've been wrong about. You can't. So, >> the
voice for one thing. Oh,
called Paris called Hassan Biker a statuto. That was kind of
up. I was kind of up. I'll be real. Your music sucks. Shut up,
Sinatra.
Shut up. Shut up. Shut the [__] up. I could actually
do the radio voice. I think I joked about this early in streaming,
right? That like, "Hey guys, do you want me to do the the actual
radio voice?" Yes. Lawyers have limited ethical obligations to
disclose information about a client's intended or ongoing crimes.
I joked about doing it. It's just like gross. It's gross. >> Just
tip $3. >> Boon definitely has estrogen rich
>> How many steroids is that on?
>> Jesus Christ.
>> It's kind
like with Pixie and Cherry and everybody. It was all like very
>> I would say with Cherry
I actually >> with Cherry was was that a criminal act in
theory? Would that have been because she hasn't been she hasn't
formally done a thing, right? >> No. So, she claims that
she has formally filed a report, a criminal report. She wasn't
suing him. She took it to the >> and yep, >> that
she gave them the evidence. From my perspective and from my experience,
this would have already been done and done if that was the case.
Especially with like the evidence that they claimed to have had
that like this was uh a pretty easy thing. But the uh but yeah,
we haven't seen or heard any of it. I I even like said before
it would have been nice to even just see like a from somebody
showing that a recording was sent to them to where we know that
this was uh put out but we we don't even >> doesn't need
to happen. Don't need don't need anybody in the public to know
any of this stuff. It's not required >> have that from
what I understand it's literally just claims and I think JCK
said that he verified this. So,
>> uh, Quimman is a person who's seen I'll just like cuz
I'm it's not me, right? I'll go lean on somebody else. Queen
has seen this evidence that the report has been filed.
>> Yeah. But, um, >> but that's it. >> So,
I was just Yeah, I was just so like outside of
outside of that, it was like just like civil stuff, but like
uh you know, with this, it's it's looking like I mean there definitely
is going to be at least some I don't want to say I mean, I guess
it would technically be a criminal investigation. Like, the cops
are going to look into it. So, I guess we'll see what happens
there. >> Yeah. Well, I mean, depending on like whether
or not So, I I wonder
if the victim is not part of this at all, what happens from there?
Because like obviously Rose would have to
uh I would assume would have to be part of this in some way.
If somebody just claims that he has
like CP of a person, but they're just like using the same like
internet sleuththed
sort of way of verifying this instead of actually going and verifying
with Rose. I wonder
uh my wand as far as I know the uh it was the
the Grinder recordings that were on there. >> As far as
I know >> how how far that goes. I don't I don't think
they have to have her be a part of it because the contention
isn't whether or not she sent it to him. The contention is whether
or not he has it,
>> Or had it. >> Yes. And but I don't know. To me,
I feel like there's without like an actual victim there with
like just photos of a person who may or may not exist. Like I
feel like there has to be an actual person who is a victim
to exist within this case. Not that they have to like actually
like be part of the court process, but that like they would have
to verify with them. You sent these images to this person, they
did accept this, you had these conversations, you did not do
this, you did do that. Like I feel like there would have to be
more information from the from the victim in some way, but I'm
not sure.
>> I'm not sure that's the case. Um because either for
instance
>> so so so I know in some cases that isn't the case. So
right if I let's say hypothetically I'm in possession of cam
but I did not get it from the like child in the >> I know
you guys couldn't tell this because I was uh not speaking but
I was here the whole time and I do have to walk away for a second
so give me two >> I got it from some random dude the local
sea sand dealer. Um I don't think that they need to reference
the victim. I think the victim could be dead and I would still
be able to have my charges
uh levied against me. >> Yeah. My first thought is like
what if they were dead? I was thinking at least like the parents
would be able to like talk about like yes this is a real person.
This is our daughter blah blah blah. But you're right that like
even in Cesam cases where the people they may not be able to
verify who the people are. They probably can at least verify
that they look like children. But then I feel like they would
still have to actually verify their ages and that like who they
are as an ID. But I don't know. I'm not sure. It just it just
>> Yeah, sure. They probably have to verify who is in the
video and their Yeah, they probably have to verify who's in the
video and their age. Otherwise, I could just say if you you at
your age send me a picture of your I could just say that's Cam,
right? Or something like that. Um and but they would just go
like who is this guy? Oh, it's this guy. He's under 18. Yeah,
that's the that's the only part that I'm talking about, but I
I don't that's probably not necessarily in all cases. Yeah. >> Yeah,
true. >> So, um so yeah, I mean I mean we'll we'll see.
It's I mean it's you know it is what it is, but yeah, I guess
uh >> did you have anything else on this you wanted to
talk to me about? Um, well, just the the only other thing was
that the in the so I because I DM'd you about this a little bit
a couple of days ago, but it seems as though like when the person
who came out with the email saying that they >> I'm back
and they published the Twitter DMs, right? >> It seems
there's a couple of problems with the Twitter DM. >> Oh,
Izzy, you got questions for me or what?
One is that like it Destiny's name
cropped on there. It is like you can tell a difference in color
in the background from where his name is to everything else on
that page. So his name is most definitely cropped on here when
you can see a difference in color between these two spots. Like
you can see like >> Hold on. But is that shading? Is that
like subtle shading in the actual UI? the the square all the
way around
and >> it's obvious that that was cropped on there. Two,
the
the followers number is a f um the amount of followers that he
had just gotten within like the last couple of days. I don't
think he had ever been at that number outside of the last couple
of days, which was 294,000.
So,
that had to have just been put on there within the last couple
of days. My thought process is that they they put this on there
um just to show who it is that's in the blue messages because
otherwise if it just said Rose, you wouldn't know who all of
the blue messages are. And so, they put that on there. But you
guys were speculating about this for a while. And so I thought,
well, this to me makes sense that like if I was going to publish
this, I would maybe put his name on there somewhere.
>> They say they don't understand why it's like that in
the DMs. No. >> So that people knew that's him
>> sending the all those messages in blue. >> And
then tell
I doubt you would put it like in such a way that it looks like
it's fabricated, right? You you would probably put like maybe
in a caption or something like that in a very obvious would have
been much smarter. This is the >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Or
if they were trying to protect her identity while also putting
this out. But if this came out in the Discord where they're trying
to find her ID, that doesn't make sense. And so that's that's
the claim is that this was part of the Discord where they're
trying to find her ID. Now I like also the fact that they were
trying to find her ID seems to make sense if he was actually
trying to get her so that he could figure out who Solo was so
that he could actually go after him legally for revenge point
and everything like that all seemed to be glazed over as well
is that like it it seemed as though he was trying to find her
and then when he could the email says that they failed at trying
to find her. So when he puts the DM the information out to
uh to DGG,
everybody kept saying, "Oh yeah, he's just trying to with Kiwi
Farms." To me, I'm thinking, "No, he's putting this out there
cuz they failed at finding her and he's hoping somebody will
find her so that he can like that >> Bro, Destiny and Ethan
are still fighting." Is crazy. No. Um,
trust me, the Tom has no understanding of why this would be going
on, right? He doesn't. He's got no idea.
>> That was my thought is that like they they couldn't
find her, so now he's just putting it out knowing that somebody
will find her. And >> Oh, no. This is a blatant lie. Actually,
it literally he Destiny doesn't even deny that he was putting
it out so his Kiwi farmers could go and try to find her to taunt
them, right?
Like he literally He literally just said this. He'll have her.
>> I mean, that seems uh
>> I mean, that seems
that seems pretty wild. Um
to like give people
>> also because Rei because Rei doesn't know and he's not
establishing this. Need to say the idea that she was a minor
was introduced in November of
So he was sending these this purported CESAM, this possible CEM
to a conversation with multiple people.
>> Yeah. In an attempt to get more information on >> That's
what I thought at first as well. It's really [__]
up to have her doc place. Then I thought, well, >> it as
long as she's disappeared that like she just disappeared and
then all of this [__] comes out and Solo is claiming
that she gave him this information to put out that for him, he
might think, well, she's giving him to do revenge on me. So,
at this point, like if she's willing to like put out all of my
dudes and I don't give a [__] if she gets doxed in
order for me to be able to find her and him to to be able to
hold them accountable for this like um but yeah, I don't know.
That's that just seems like >> But even that the idea that
like he could be doxing somebody who could expose that he was
minor, >> right? Which is again why it seems reasonable
that he didn't he still didn't believe that she was a minor until
recently. Um cuz yeah, like solo said that to him early on and
it didn't seem as though he believed Solo when he said it. >> Yeah.
But it's like, you know, you know, at at one point, at what point
is it like, hey, this is you're getting all this information
about her age and like that should probably be a little bit careful
with how this works. And and I don't know, it just to me feels
like >> it feels like he is uh just very very being very
reckless. >> Well, that's what I'm saying is it seems as
though that was before >> all of like more recently where
it seems like within the last like four days where we actually
knew that she was under 18 whereas before all of this, it didn't
seem like he even thought that was plausible. didn't seem like
he even thought like consider that >> he thought it was
possible. He absolutely thought he was it was possible. Tom is
not Tom is afraid to >> Feels like he had like almost no
information to go off of to say that she was over the age of
18.
>> Dude, this is this is just tragic that this is the only
thing they can put in front of viewers.
I'm sitting here. I would I'm sitting here and I'm like, "Hey,
I would I talk about this stuff. I'd be nice to these
>> Very afraid. >> She claims that she showed him
a college >> Where was that? It was. So, he had said this
behind the scenes a couple of times, but Willie Mack recently
put out some DMs where he said this as well. And >> I I'm
sorry. Behind the scenes, Tom Tom was in the chat, wasn't he?
Tom was in that Finding Rose group chat. Let's be real. Let's
be real. Tom had to have been in there. I can feel it. I can
feel it in my bones. >> Boom. It was uh >> I didn't
see that. >> Uh I mean, she told me she was 19 and she
was in college when we were chatting. Oh, well. She's actually
17. I'm pretty sure even Solo said she lied. Let's see. >> Let's
just be totally real here. >> Said that she showed him
an ID.
Uh,
>> wait, I'm sorry. A college ID as a college ID as in
she went to a college or a college ID with her birthday on it
>> as like I think that's the the idea is that she actually
had her birthday on it. Um, >> oh, okay. >> I thought
she showed me a student ID or something, but I can never know
about those messages because our first ones were on Twitter and
they deleted their account. Um, and then he says, "But Tinder
does some kind of age check. I don't remember if they required
an upload or not. Uh, it's been a while and this Rose person
had a Tinder, so they were at least willing to lie about their
age there. So, yeah, I I like in 2019 I had done Tinder and they
required an ID from me, but apparently that >> what there's
no way he just said that, >> That was like a state-by-state
thing and different places required IDs and >> What state?
What state was Tom in in 2019? Do we know where where he was
in
>> I have to go find this now. Georgia in 2019. Really?
In certain in certain states, you require an ID for Tinder? >> Yeah.
even even like different countries. They just recently they like
rolled it out in different countries uh like nationwide, but
they said that the if he didn't actually get sent her Tinder
account, even if that was the case, that still wouldn't be verification.
So, and there's no he doesn't ever say that. He never says, you
know, yeah, she like I they have to give ID verification for
Tinder and she sent me her Tinder. He doesn't say that. She he
just says that she said that she was on Tinder. So, that still
wouldn't be any sort of reasonable verification from my perspective.
>> Now, this is the AI summary. So, hold on. In 2022, Tinder's
age verification for users in Georgia or other countries. Oh,
Georgia. In Georgia,
state of Georgia. Georgia. US. I don't see it. But that was for
the country. Tinder. Let's go. US age verification 2022. I'm
looking for like a state by state even here. Georgia
Tinder age verification. Georgia's a age verification law. Dude,
I I don't know, man. This odd, dude. I ah
maybe >> I thought it was just like a common knowledge
thing that there's a lot of >> my link is right there.
Hold on. Yeah, Maximus, you are absurdly
sometimes. I understand you just linked me this 2025. Judge blocks
George's new social media age verification law before it's set
to start. So, this tells me what the age verification process
was in 2022. This tells me in 2022 what the age verification
process was
in the state of Georgia. That's what we're looking for. It says
there was no law or social media companies to get parents permission.
So, this is for all social media companies. This doesn't say
what Tinder's actual like rules were in Georgia. Tom did say
2019. That's true. Hold on. But this is for all social media
Maximus, not not just Tinder. Obviously, all social media would
have a would be would take longer to get age verification than
just Tinder, right? An app explicitly made to >> underage
people on Tinder. I thought this was just literally a common
knowledge thing. Um, but I guess maybe not. I'm pretty confident
he's just lying. I I'm pretty confident he's just
>> Um I don't know >> because I I've literally heard
of I literally went to school with people who would go like on
my Tinder account when they were like 16 or 17. They would talk
about on my Tinder account. >> Okay, Maximus, I'm going
to ask you when you link stuff, please click on it first and
read it and make sure it has the information about the age verification
process in 2022 or 2019. Please don't just link before actually
clicking >> my Tinder account. >> Thank you. How
old are you? And I'm like near my late 30s right now. >> It
would have been like over a decade >> Late 20s. He means
>> when I was in high >> cuz it's really
I
>> Damn. I thought you were I thought you were a good bit
younger than me for some reason. I thought you said >> that
mental [__] just tipped $3.
Wait, do you guys really think I'm functionally retained? Put
a one in chat for yes.
in the past. I remember you asking me how old I was before and
then telling me that you thought I looked a lot younger and then
Yeah, I thought that you ended up, you know, like a lot younger
than me, but I'm 36, so about to turn 37. >> Yeah, I got
you. >> Yeah, we didn't have we didn't have to do when
I was in school. So, it was uh for me it was >> really
doesn't realize he just said late
>> at all. I just remember having to take a picture of
my ID and then also take a picture of my face. But I remember
I was worried that I had to that whatever picture I used for
my verification would end up as my profile picture or something
like that because I didn't want to have to actually I didn't
want that to be my >> Did Tom get like his identity stolen
by a fake Tinder app or something? >> My profile picture.
So I remember like numerous times exing out of the face verification
thinking nah I got to go like shave and like that if this is
a >> Wait, I'm sorry. Did I just say There's people in
my chat saying I said I was in my late 30s. You did? >> Did
I say that? >> Oh my god. No, I said I'm in my late 20s.
I'm almost 30. >> Oh, okay. Yeah, I was thinking I was
like, "Wait, you're in your late 30s." >> No, I just I
just I just straight up Nah, bro.
Too soon. You threw me off, dude. You totally threw me off, dude.
I was like, "Wait, dude. You're like my >> I don't think
a liar here, bro. Hey, we're talking about info. I'm spreading
a little bit of misinformation. You feel me? No. >> Yeah.
Okay. So, yeah. Okay. So, yeah. So, you are you are a good bit
younger than me. Okay. Um Okay. Somebody's asking if they can
talk to you. His name's a Cheeto. Do you want to >> Yeah,
I don't I don't mind. Okay. A >> Uh-huh. So, spoiler alert.
This is not a >> How are you? I'm under the water. Please
help me. You have too much raining. >> How are you? I'm
under the water.
>> Never mind.
>> Well done. >> All right. Okay. >> Okay.
All right. All right. Uh well,
>> yeah, that was about it. I can't uh I can't think of
much else that that I wanted to get into. I think uh >> Yeah.
Uh okay. Well, yeah. Yeah, I was just curious kind of where your
head was at on this. >> I do not think that was Kathy.
I'm pretty confident that was not Kathy. I'm just saying.
>> 4K points. Assan is bad.
Assan is bad. >> I guess if anything else swaps off, I'll
I'll uh I'll >> again explicitly there's specific state
rules. Maximus, it's fine. But um it's >> Don't worry about
it. >> Yeah, hit me up. I think Tom might have walked into
something that was like opt in and not realized that it was uh
that it wasn't required or something. I'll >> hit you up.
Yep. >> Yeah. If you're on the if you're doing uh like
>> Okay, I'm out. Uh okay. You just say the app doesn't
have that feature 2019 >> panels at any point and you want
some >> Yeah, I know there's a new tweet about Destiny.
We'll we'll get to it. Just give me a sec.
>> Yeah, I'd probably do that. Yeah. I was going to do
a Tik Tok thing today, but I
>> I'm I'm being confusing. So, here's what you want to
know. You want to know definitively whether in the state of Georgia
in 2019
they had age verification on Tinder. There are a couple different
ways to do that. I would probably just use chat GPT personally
because that will actually search a whole bunch of old links
for you, right? Uh you could ask it about like what the actual
state laws were in Georgia in the in the year of our Lord 2019.
Sorry. Or what the the laws were in Georgia. You could ask it
what Tinder's overall US policy was in 2019. It would know all
these things. >> I don't know. I'm just putting off lazy.
>> I don't know why
>> unless he was cheating on Rose at the time. Yeah, I
don't I think he could easily be cheating. I just take his word
for it in 2019 because that's the just fact check what he said.
>> I don't know why. Um, I hate setting up his whole thing.
But >> well, did you get the Bluetooth thing that I was
telling you to get?
>> Chat GPT is not just lie and make things up. You can
easily just click in. You just ask it. You find the thing. You
ask it the question and you say, "Can you provide me an article
to source this from?" And then you read the article that it sources
it from. I don't know. People are so bad at using technology.
It's shocking. It's like totally shocking that people are this.
They're like, I typed in the Google search and they give me what
I did immediately and uh that's a really bad thing. It's so easy
to use these pieces of technology and people just say, oh, so
bad yourself in a video game. >> Just to be clear, I found
out so I was telling you that there's a a thing called Remo,
but I couldn't find one with the Bluetooth button. And that was
my issue is I kept trying to find one with a Bluetooth button.
Apparently, none of the new ones have a button. You just connect
to it. So, all of them have Bluetooth on them and they're all
like, yeah, like 20 bucks. They're very cheap. Um, you can use
them for like your mic as well and plug up numerous mics to it
and change the sound on it. Change like your voice. They have
like voice correction where like the uh Lil Wayne, you know,
Kanye West, you know, in the night like all that. You can you
can do all sorts of stuff on it. I've got like clapping noises
on it. Uh, laughing >> Oh, what's up, Queenman? How's it
going? >> We stand with Destiny against Ethan Klein. Okay.
sacrificed a thousand
barely legal or barely illegal young
took one. Okay, stop. >> Uhhuh. Uhhuh.
>> You laughed and said, "Okay, stop. I'm just sitting
here watching you cook. Okay. I don't know. I don't have to tell
you. Okay, stop. I don't have to stop. I'm not doing right now.
>> I just I'm I'm Listen, I regulate myself." Okay. >> Yeah.
Okay. Hold on a second. See if we can get the interpol agent
queen on here. There we go. There we go. Let's go. Someone said
I could just make this avatar have black hair and then it's Aiden
as well. >> What do you think about that? >> Um that
sounds anti to me. >> Um
yeah.
>> No. Aiden's hotel in Mortar just burned down. Do you
know this? >> Him and Perry not have a good time hanging
out. >> This is this is not a joke. Like not a joke at
all. His hotel in Malta burned down and he was like meant to
stay there for four nights but he's getting turfed out after
one and he's not getting a
Very awesome. >> I was reading his logs in server crying
about it earlier. >> Is he is he now? >> Him and
Perry roommates now. >> No, I think No, I think he's just
move I think he's just moving on from I think.
>> Is he like solo traveling across Europe or with a streaming
set? >> Yeah, not I don't know if he's got a streaming
set. I think he's just got a laptop. Wow, that's funny. Then
Perry Yeah, Perry lives in Malta. They They met up.
I'm pretty sure they met up. I don't know if they stream together,
but they met up for sure. >> They meet up. I think they
stream >> Oh, man.
And then stumbling to some free snacks for my kids. And this
is guy looking at dogs in a shoe. >> Th This is just like
>> That's actually funny. Okay, I'm sorry. That's actually
>> I'm going to be real. Like that's it's a funny angle.
He doesn't land that one. I'm going to be honest. That that one
did not quite land for me. This this the post this part of the
part of the post I like more was mocking the Instagram stories.
I think that's a good angle because this guy is literally like
just
>> Instagram stories is Twitter where people can't talk
back to me. That's that's what this is for Ethan. Wait, is there
a new
>> free Palestine mobiliz
from this river to the sea Palestine will be free? All it took
was the two closest to him turning on him. And he is uh >> this
is nothing will turn you into a Palestine supporter quicker than
listening to Ethan Klein talk. Okay. >> Nothing will turn
you into a Palestine supporter quicker than trusting certain
people with vital information. Okay. What happened to Nick Fuentes?
I don't know if you know this. Okay. Same process. Is this one
real? This one is real. I'm looking at his actual Twitter. >> Look
at that video. Look at this new tweet. Look >> that feeling
when Ethan Klein finds out his dad. >> Oh my goodness.
I was 16 years old. >> Wow. Look at you guys here. >> No
way. No. That's a That's a That's a bushy mustache for a 16-year-old
father of his. Okay. That's a bushy ass mustache right there.
>> Dad's 21 and I'm six. >> It's basically morale.
Ethan's dad. >> Yeah, that's not Listen, that that's not
33 and 17. Okay, I'm sorry. Missed on this one. Total miss. Cell
phone called yourself as well. Total misstep.
also a pedophile. >> Bro, you would not trouble. I know.
>> 21 and 16. >> Well, you know what? I was more
mature than he was. >> She was an old soul. >> Well,
I believe that. I actually do believe that. >> But look
at her. I mean, she
just came off the cover of >> dude 20. >> Look at
her at 16. She looks so hot.
I that 16-year-old now.
>> Were you guys Were you guys having a >> none of
your business?
>> What? That's my go.
>> Why would he ask that? Why would he add? That's weird.
>> Did you guys, you know, the deal? >> She was 18.
>> Not
in love.
>> Oh, you lie. >> Okay, this is an awesome segment
though. What the >> That's so crazy. Yeah, you could not
do that today. I mean, that would be just like, whoa there, buddy.
>> Buttons are open. >> Oh my.
>> That's That's crazy. Yeah, this is a total cell phone
pose from Destiny. That's I know he's watching your stream late
at night. Okay.
>> Message Deeperama on Twitter. Okay. Get this guy to
go strike your tweets.
>> Dude, Deeper's been >> I keep telling people I'm
like Deeperama will have 100,000 followers by the end of uh I
think it's D33, right? It's all threes and all fours. >> Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Uh,
yeah, he'll have 100,000 followers by the end of 2024 or sorry,
2026. Not a time machine. And Destiny starts trying to kill people
I hate.
>> Okay. Can't make this stuff up. Oh, she retweeting Cherry.
Let's go. Nicholas
dude, there were some really good ones earlier today. This is
funny. The Lubu thing. Say the virtues.
Oh my god. Is this actually food shops here? I don't I don't
Okay.
there's uh I just kind of wonder if Destiny's like lamenting
the quality drop.
The quality drop in the community. The quality drop of the orbiters.
Tom's out here being like, "Yeah, I totally [__]
17-year-old." Yeah. Yeah. You know what? Show me some hot 13year-olds
and I'll I'll let you know. >> The DG is just so funny.
Unfortunately, >> I know. I know. I'm trying not to propagate
it, but it's too funny cuz their the quality of all of their
posts, all of their memes has dropped so much. >> It's
just I've already seen it catch so much and it's like I it's
just over. That's like one that is just so catchy and so funny.
It's just like
>> I'm trying I'm trying to avoid using it and I I I
just don't want to.
Yeah, I didn't use like, you know, I would never said foot soldiers
for like a long time because it's like, you know, do you want
to just like, you know, let these people like their [__]
through your content and all this [__] like you don't
actually want to be doing that as much as Destiny likes to pretend
that everyone's just actively engaging with KB forms, you don't
actually generally want to be doing the the whole like play into
KS thing cuz they're quite fickle and if you don't do what they
want, they might be just as vindictive against you.
So, you generally don't want to do that. But there are just some,
and Destiny knows this, too. There are just some
nicknames or images that he's used in the past, uh, that come
from there that do just catch that dude just hit like anywhere
on the internet, obviously. I mean, he's using all the snark
[__] right now. So, I mean, this guy can't even cry.
Like, that's just Ethan's Kiwi Farms thread. So, >> hello
DJers. Are we really going to let this Ethan guy get away with
trying to kill Tiny? We going to let him do that, guys? Dude,
I I tried to explain to people because um we talked about the
Hutch thing. There was some comment that came up that was referring
to like you and Hutch. I can't remember if it was a tweet or
what, but it was basically saying that like you all somebody
just asked Queman like or Hutch asked Queman to like tell his
fans to take it easy and he refused and said Hutch was disgusting
for asking. I'm like that's not what happened. >> That's
not what happened. And I tried to explain to people that like
with KF a lot of the time if you let them manipulate you, if
you show them that you'll let them manipulate you, like it's
over. It's already over at that point. Like they'll they'll just
keep with you forever. Like it it's like a it's like a like a
horror like a demon from some horror series where like as soon
as you like get scared of it when you walk around a corner, >> it's
it's not even like that deep. It is. It is just like any troll
community, any Alog community, whatever it is. The moment you
start playing into whatever [__] game they're playing,
you're like, that's it. You're you're you're part of it, you
know? >> And the second you stop, it's not good.
It's not good. Uh Sunday kind of broke the loop, right? I think
Sunday kind of broke out, but he kind of had to chill for a while.
I think he was doing he was doing like thumbnails and I thought
that was a little crazy for a little bit. Read the horse tweet.
Deeperama's horse tweet or Oh, hold on. Ethan Klein's children
when they finally get to crawl on a floor that isn't covered
in their father's feces.
steal this tweet. Just go steal this
>> Just start retweeting Deepama. Okay, it's fine.
H
>> dude, the the tweet where it's like, well, uh
Willy, make sure reading the messages from Destiny like
Chorn
as his eyes out of his skull. His skull shoots through the roof.
>> So good,
Oh my god. Okay, hold on. There was a Destiny tweet we didn't
even cover. Hold on. Ethan was like, "Dude, I really respected
you. I want to see where this goes. Stephen, you're a very smart
and funny guy. I've been following your career for a long time
since you were cleaning carpets in the in between Starcraft 2
games. I saw you transition to streaming full-time, which as
someone who was also working a 9 to5, I found really inspiring.
It was soon after I took the same chance on myself, inspired
in part by you, to become a full-time creator. Later on, I came
around to hold on. Um, >> this is like how you know this
guy is like lying through his teeth right now is because this
is just like the
like if you took any given interview of Destiny where they ask
him life questions. This is the narrative of Destiny's own life
that he gives. This isn't like I've actually watched the content
and these are the things I enjoyed or these are the points where
I I was, you know, app. It's like just I watched an interview
with you. Here's the start of your career. It's like
cleaning carpets between Starcraft games. It's like pure like
uh
manipulation. >> This is not the song I was looking for.
This is not the song I was looking for. It is. He's basically
trying to I agree with you, but I don't know. I think I think
it's got to it's got to flip, right? It's got to flip to like
totally on this guy. You would think >> send this whole
thing. Sorry. >> What did you guys send? Oh god.
Are you good? Are you good? I'm going to read the rest of this
tweet. Okay. Uh later on, I came around to your political streaming
content. A genre you pioneered. You've Oh, I was going to do
epic music for this and it it didn't work out. Sorry. I I forgot
the name of the song. Wait, no, no, no, no, no. It's like uh
Hold on.
Did I just remember the name of the song? Nope, I did not. What
the is the Ah, don't even worry about it. Never mind. This definitely
wasn't it either. God damn it. We lost it, guys. We lost it.
I'm just going to read later on. When I came around to your political
streaming content, a genre you pioneered. You've had such a long
and accomplished career that anyone would be extremely proud
of. I am genuinely sad about the great potential that you had
and what you've for and for what was thrown away because vices
took over your life. As a parent, you know the implications and
ramification of chatting with a 15-year-old. You know how a teenager
looks up to adults they admire and how easily they can be manipulated.
The time for irreverent jokes is over. You need help. This is
a long pattern of deviency with children uh teenagers. Teenagers,
I hope you take the time to understand what inside you is missing
and why you would urge a grown man to flirt with a 15-year-old
or sorry, why that would urge a grown man to flirt with a 15-year-old.
I'm not taking pleasure in any of this. It's all very sad. I
do hope you find the help and peace you need because children
deserve better. I think he's saying 15 because of the MLG person,
the person who sent him the bikini photos, right? Anyway, you
need help. I'm clapping and crying. You learned more from Hassan
than he ever could than he could have ever hoped. And you now
you've come full circle on the snark train. I hope CPS can save
your children before the worms turn them into RFK clones. Gas
bag. Turns out everybody's got a little bit of a everyone's got
a little snarker in them. Okay. Everyone's got a little piece
of snark in their heart. Everyone is a snarker. Okay. All of
these people who pretend gas bag. I assume that has to do with
Ethan's uh horrible lactose intolerance. No. He have like really
bad lactose intolerance. He like his pants constantly or IBS.
One of the two. >> This guy sucks at this. He's so bad
at this. It's so annoying. >> He does. Listen, they
they aren't trained in the snarking ways. Okay. They're not They're
not ready to be snarkers. They're late to the game. Although,
I don't understand. R/ Destiny is basically Hassan Stark. I don't
like should he not be better at this?
Was he not better at this? I thought he was just better at this.
Was it really? I think it was obvious >> time when he was
maybe when he was maybe better, but there's like a point where
like half of his like attacks and [__] ped into this
weird >> stuff. Do you remember the Lwig tweet about cutie
Cinderella and how badly he got and how stupid he looked when
he was like trying to make the joke about how people were off
to cutie Cinderella's like uh deep fake.
That was maybe where I knew like, oh, this guy lost it like entirely.
Like, he's not funny anymore.
No, what tweet? Uh, Ludwig was making fun of him and so he tweeted
at Lewig like a picture of Cutie Cinderella crying was like,
I guess we'll all like we can all have a piece of your girlfriend.
And Lwig replied with something like, "Yeah, that's my girlfriend.
I love her. Where's your wife?" And Bessie just got completely
like a hund times ratioed. It was so over, right? It was just
a It was such a stupid tweet. Uh, where is this tweet? Can I
find it? Can I find it? >> I think the exact point in Destiny
was like completely unfunny was the the guzzling buckets have
come Sam the moment. I think that was like from that moment it
was probably that's like when it was totally dead.
>> you really look back
>> maybe there definitely moments after that. Wait, are
you talking about when he said it about Sam Cedar originally
or when he um when he had the debate with Sam Cedar?
>> Um,
either one.
But when he whenever he said it about Sam Seda, probably the
first time >> he had like this exchange with Lewig.
Ledwig does the what' he say? Oh yeah. So Destiny kind of goes
off on Lewig and people. Lewig says what he say [__]
me for. Destiny interpret this as a joke. By the way, Destiny
thought this was a joke when Ledwig is like why'd you go after
me, bro?
He's like he thought it was a joke.
And so he responded with this cutie Cinderella crying and and
uh what is it?
>> Yeah, this is what I mean. Like everything's in this
guy's mind. This is what I'm I'm talking about. Like the guzzling
buckets have come thing. >> The reason I look back on that
as being like the moment where it's like, okay, that seems really
unfunny here is cuz it is just a moment where his his deranged
mind is showing through so clearly when he's trying to be funny.
>> Okay. Yes. For people to understand, Destiny didn't
know what this meme was, so he Googled it and he probably read
that this there's some like kind of weird situation going on
with this 50 tweet. But the meme is just why did he say [__]
me for? Like I'm unrelated. Why' you say me? Right? That's the
meme. That's all Lewig's doing here. There's no reason to read
a joke into it. It's stupid. Okay. And so he went hard and yeah,
11,000 versus uh
142,000
likes on Lewig's tweet. Okay. Oof. Anyway, I think I think that
was the moment for me. Sorry. That was the moment where I knew
it was over. Oh god, is he still tweeting more? No. Then Desessie
thought he won that exchange, too. He did not.
Bye. Food shops is live. Good luck, Jesus. Gal
check replies. >> Why food shops is live? What thing to
>> Nothing. Nothing. We got nothing here. Destiny asked
a girl for her number and she pulled out a leaprog. Oh, they're
doing the the memes again.
and Courtney
Why? Okay. Why? Can you just link the tweet? Can you How How
about you just link the tweet? Can you just tweet link the tweet?
Can you please for the love of God? These people are keep saying,
"Uh, check this, check that."
Nope. >> It's like there's nothing interesting in there,
so I don't know what they need to >> Oh, yep. I don't know.
Check. Quan's cowardice. Splceito guy's got a problem with you.
What' you do to him?
>> he's got a problem with me. This guy's like deranged.
What's up? What's your issue? >> Well, originally I got
in here to talk about something else and and I thought Quimman
joined. >> You're a you're like a deranged hater.
>> Cuz you're like crazy. You're like always posting crazy
stuff.
>> What? Name something. >> What do you have to say?
What do you have to say? >> No, no, no, no. You just said
I post range stuff. Name something. Anything.
>> Little Destiny Junior here. I'm pretty sure you were
saying um you think legal in chat earlier. >> Did I say
that? >> Yeah, I think so.
>> in chat earlier >> crazy. No, it's just it's just
funny like you used to show up to J Talk stream a lot right at
late at night. You know, you end your stream you guys have your
little EP streams and then like then Destiny put down the knee
on your neck. You kind of stopped showing up and then now Destiny
No, no, no. Hold up, hold up. I'm not finished. Don't know why
you're talking. And now >> you stopped.
Um, and now shut up. >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I think
I think you just failed to take into account here. Okay.
>> We got We can't do our cabaling in the open anymore.
We used to be able to do the cabaling in the open. Now we have
to do it all offline. >> Okay. Ironic jokes. Cabal. Yeah.
Funny. Funny. They just keep sweeping for Queen here. Yeah. What
was the irony there? Is there an actual cabal?
>> Holy [__] Really? >> Literally pulled
my tweet up yesterday. What are you talking about? Dude, you
got to delete the stream. That's how he's going to find us. >> He
already like named pretty much the whole cabal in that in that
DG record. >> I don't know how he found it. We're so >> Yeah,
he was like pretty >> No, you're doing this on stream.
What do you mean you're so careful? You're doing this on stream.
Are you stupid? >> What do you mean? >> No, I mean
listen
to minor and holding CP despite
>> What do you What do you mean by what do you mean by
stupid? Aren't you Mexican? >> Jesus Christ. >> Okay.
Well, you only know that because recently you're like, "This
guy, this guy actually sounds black."
>> How many black people do you know in your life?
>> Did Queen get a black wrong? Did Queen miss black?
>> I'm getting rough. >> Well, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't actually identify. I don't count it because I didn't
actually guess it. >> Oh, no. Actually, sorry, sorry. No,
no, no, no, no. Sorry, sorry, sorry. He was like, "I was actually
really thinking about him last night and I really want to identify
his race
and like I really want him to be black."
So I kind of think like those black >> Why you making this
gay? What's your problem, bro?
>> What I'm making
am I wrong? Were you thinking of me that night
speculating on my race? Am I wrong on >> You called in.
You called in about No. I thought that guy was white. I thought
that guy was from chat >> before.
Did you not say that on stream? You were speculating on my race.
>> I was speculating. I was internally speculating on your
race. Yeah. >> And not on stream. Privately to yourself,
right? >> Privately in my own head. Yeah. >> Okay.
That's just want to clear that up. So now you're saying I'm I'm
making it gay, but I'm just rehashing what you >> You tried
to phrase it in like a homeerotic way. >> How did I phrase
it intentionally?
You're saying I was like I had a specific desire for you to be
a certain race. I think that's putting a kind of an implication
on it. >> Okay. Can you tell me what about my voice came
off as black that didn't come off as a spe spe spe spe spe spe
spe spe specific way that you want >> it? It doesn't come
off like white. That that was kind of >> it doesn't come
off as white.
>> Hello sir. Sad. >> Okay. All right.
>> Oh boy. Dude, you think uh you remember what happened
when Vos basically said that Ethan Klein was being like ridiculous?
Remember what happened to Vos?
You think did a whole episode on him and you think that's gonna
happen to Destiny now? You think You think Lion's gonna go do
like multiple episodes on him in a row? >> Oh, Ethan's
a Ethan's scared.
>> Think so. >> Yeah, 100%. They I don't understand
why. Well, I mean, I say I'm using that as a standin really for
doesn't want to take the fight because it could be like purely
strategic. Doesn't want to fight Destiny and Son at the same
time basically. But um yeah, he obviously doesn't want to take
the fight because he's saying he doesn't want to litigate it
further
community. I wouldn't be surprised if
you know I'm sure if I go and watch a Nicholas Dioro stream,
I'm sure Nicholas Dioro would be saying something like I don't
I don't think Ethan should engage with Destiny at all. I think
he should just ban all the DJs from his audience and not engage
with anything Destiny says at all or anything Destiny does at
all and just uh and just immediately move on. And I'm sure Ethan's
behavior followed that immediately after. And uh well just ignore
it. Well, everyone should just pretend it's not happening, >> dude.
I saw a I saw what did I see? It was like um Oh, it was some
criticism. Never mind. I lost it already. It's something people
were complaining about basically um I think Ethan. Was it Ethan
or was it uh was it Ethan or was it Nick who's complaining about
Destiny doing the what about Hassan thing and it's just like
bro we've uh we watched Ethan do this for like months now. What
about Hassan doing this? What about Hassan doing that? Can anybody
over there really actually complain about the Hassan what aboutism?
Uh I don't think so. Just is upset about what? What is just upset
about? Rampage is defending his son. Well, apparently the wrestler
didn't die. So apparently we just heard that and the wrestler
didn't die so it's probably not that big a deal. Why are you
linking me just comments? Hold on a second. I don't want to talk
about Hassan or Destiny. Maybe I picked the wrong community.
I mean it was a Destiny like fan community in the start. I don't
Yeah, >> Yeah, 100%. Yes. >> Like I I don't know
what to tell you. Um kind of sucks. Justin is a fun guy to have
around, but damn. Listen, I fully support your crusade against
Ethan, but you have to do better than this. Go after Hila for
her brother not talking to her anymore or something. We're on
the higher deeper challenge now. He needs a ghost rider. Can
work proono. We can do something massive here.
Uh sometimes we talk about pirate software. Well, we talk about
all kinds of different things, but like I don't know.
Unfortunately, right now, if you don't want to talk about Destiny,
when we're like two days removed from finding out that Rose was
17, three days >> it's like, I'm sorry if you don't want
to talk about Destiny while he's having the biggest crash out
of his entire >> I don't know what to tell you, man. It's
an online drama community. That's the drama right now. This O
guy is posting every single tweet between these two. That's his
entire timeline right now.
>> Can you imagine how the orc tweets would be worded if
his son was talking like Destiny talking? But I noticed the orc
tweet is quite timid in the phrasing.
>> Yeah, Destiny takes cl aim at Ethan Klein's dad.
This is uh what is this dude? Like nobody wants to take a swing.
Like all of the biggest EGers or or people who like have watched
for a long time, they're scared to take a swing right now. They're
like I've watched him. I've I've thought he was like dead before
and then the people who take swings like end up getting killed.
They're all like scared to really take swings right now. Red
Bar cover Destiny, it's over. Is this the Red Bar episode
>> Red Bar showed my tweet today. >> You said that.
Yeah. >> Me and Destiny are best friends now because of
that happened. So,
>> that's why it's going. >> What What What was Red
Bar's reaction to >> I don't know. I didn't say it cuz
I couldn't uh rewind.
how long does it take for episodes to come out? >> Anyway,
Destiny didn't even do it really. It's cuz um [__]
Kathy emailed it to him. Oh, what?
>> Kathy emailed Red Bar alerting him that Destiny had
retweeted a
video of him.
>> Oh,
my clip. >> I see.
>> You watch any of that uh Tom all relevant debate? Check
any of that out. >> Saw like a brief bit of it through
your stream. I didn't real much of it. >> I don't know.
I It's hard to have that conversation without pointing out that
uh Solo informed him that she was underage. Oh, I see. This is
uh Sya pinging Just
don't Don't make Just comment on everything about Israel. Okay.
[__] silly.
He's our resident guy, but don't make him comment on everything
about Israel. All right. It's kind of [__] up. I
heard a teeny tiny Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. You say he's just
Is he a total Zogbot in the [__] Discord? Is he like
always showing Israel? >> Yeah, you know that though. You
literally know that. >> Yeah.
So, of course, people >> Why did you Why did you ask that
>> Yeah, because you left that out when you said it. It's
not just >> He's Israeli. There aren't a lot of Israelis
that aren't total Zogbots. I don't know if you know this. It's
like most of the country. It was implied when I said he was Israeli.
>> Oh, I didn't even hear you say Israeli. I thought he
just said he was >> Oh, well said without much else. >> He's
always shelling Israel. Yeah, he's going to get tagged about
Israel stuff.
>> maybe. I'm checking
got here. Yeah. Okay. Okay. What am I? I think I got through
my whole thing today. Connor said he will upload that VOD, by
the way. I'm not even sure. It's He's like It's going to take
too long. It's not going to be relevant anymore. >> No,
it it will be relevant. I need to see Connor's lolly arguments.
>> Wait, is this the VOD where his wife comes in then and
tells him to >> stop? That one's still up. That one's still
up. >> Okay. All right. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Oh, [__] I didn't get a chance to show get a chance
to show Lav any of the funny clips. Oh well.
Tom saying he attracted to 17year-olds
which like isn't okay. I like there's a way to say that. I don't
know why you got to giga chat it. >> Also that Destiny
Cop stream earlier was exceptionally bad. That was like um the
worst it's been. I think I don't know if it was today or or yesterday.
I said we're like approaching
like I'm dodging my wife's lies like Neo levels, but we're definitely
pretty close
to that to that type of cringe again. >> Yeah. What What
was the the worst uh I mean I also I think he was like actually
trying to just make people upset who were reacting to it. Like
I think there was a lot of that when he does the whole thing
where it's like guys it's important to just stick to your principles
and you you don't like rage out and try to hurt people just cuz
like they upset you, okay? You got to stick to your principles.
That's what's the most important thing. I'm like, bro, like that's
I feel like that's just being said to upset people. That's
right? I'm not going to go after like a
>> narrative like that to his audience and they'll up each
cynical. >> I can't believe Ethan would look at my Snark
thread. That audience is really cool though. All the all the
H3 viewers, they're actually all >> so cynical. It's so
like come on. >> No, they're actually really cool. And
like I think they know that like Snark is bad and and like Ethan's
using Snark against me now. All that calculation for him to go
to Twitter and just start posting all of the Snark things against
Ethan. Not exactly. I don't know. Like >> you don't realize
the the DGs are in so deep. Okay. That that there is no coming
back from it. They're totally embedded. The whole Reddit is SCOP.
>> Yeah. Oh, dude. I there was some threat of yeah the
destiny in exact is exactly why live shows are important dude
dude
it's tough it's tough to watch GG line is that Destiny is just
doing the snarking back to Ethan to show Ethan how bad it is
to believe lies from snarkers
dude can this really psychologically affect Ethan anymore joking
about CPS calls or skulls or on his floor can this really psychologically
affect him is that possible yes it does.
It feels like there's no way. How much do you love me now? Wait,
what is this? You just link me what? Tell me this is Connor's
stream uh on DMCA. It's not >> I don't know. Um >> just
link me the live of Tom Foolery from a day ago. L me the full
live of Tom Fury from a day ago. Cool. I love you. I love you,
Critical Ride TV. Thank you. Big stuff. Press play. >> How
about you?
>> Oh, this one. Yeah, this one is him joking, but we'll
watch it. >> Go find all of the hottest 13 there and he
tell you this pops up.
>> Did I skip it?
>> Hold on. I I will just pull a clip for you. Tom answers
questions about
>> Tom, last question.
Would you be willing to say that postpubescent 13year-olds
could be attractive to you at your age now? I don't know. Um,
how about you? Go find all of the hottest 13-year-olds that you
can find. Collect a bunch of pictures of them and then send them
to me and I'll tell you if I think they're hot or not. Okay,
Tom, last question. >> That's a joke for better or worse.
That's a joke. That's not him saying I find 13's hot. 13-year-olds
hot. Okay,
that's not what that is. Anyway, holy, I'm uh eight and a half
hour stream, guys. Big stream tonight. Thank you for being here.
I'm going to raid out. Probably going to raid. Really? All relevant.
Yeah. All right. All relevant. Oh, he's watching the uh French
guy. Maybe we check that out at some point here. Maybe we check
it out. Have a good night, guys. I'll be back tomorrow.
Talk to you later. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Bye. Good night.